[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et bonjour tout le monde salut le Vlad
ah salut tout le monde salut la
francophonie donc Vlad on est parti pour
pour la deuxième partie alors attends
c'est comme toujours un peu la guerre
des caméras j'ai envie de te dire on a
on commence à avoir l'habitude
mais on voit les joueurs là déjà sur sur
la grande cam et ça c'est la bonne
nouvelle ils vont envoyer
le premier coup au 4 des 4 alors pour
Yann d'après toi mon Vlad
pas possible
j'aurais été sûr que c'est bah qui était
sûr que ce soit le 4e elle m'a dit ah
non c'est pas sûr parce que il devait
pas répéter les lignes que les jouets
déjà ce que on a prévu pas par contre il
ne veut pas de deuxième grosse idée sur
l'espagnol le bon et de toute manière
c'est la grosse Croatie de comment dire
checker ton adversaire au début du match
qu'est-ce que tu as contre 4 qu'est-ce
que tu as contre des cadres c'est c'est
la grosse cohésique oui mais pour donner
de la bouffe à deux secondes mais dans
le match du précédent contre
Magnus Yann il s'était enféré dans le 4
il a il avait envoyé du 4 du 4 du 4 et
il en était jamais sorti bah justement
de toutes les règles comment tu joues le
match en fait établi d'ouvrir les cartes
les unes après les autres 4 des 4
éventuellement même C4 oui et de toute
manière parfois si tu joues toujours le
même coup le même ligne de succondance
savent plus quoi faire tous les fichiers
sont là et ok tu veux que on travaille
mon travail
nous montrer qui est-ce que le prépare
dans les ouvertures fermées et ça y est
donc ce soir enfin déjà pendant les
parties les succendants donnés
à fond ce que on va voir maintenant dans
le futur
je crois au moins fou et F4 fulf 4 par
contre plutôt pas parce que faute 4 ici
c'est important je crois que tu as
oublié de mentionner au troisième coup
H3
[Rires]
normal
parce que nepo est assez nouveau aux
ouvertures fermées avec les Blancs
et donc on va laisser 3 c'est plus
facile de limiter le choix de
sa gamme
ça veut dire que presque sûr après ce
délai il va bouffer avec lui parce que
incroyable je pense que si je peux me
tromper bien sûr mais très possible que
les gens me fais ça dans sa vie ce tour
de quoi avec le noir en fait même si
c'est très très populaire à la c'est le
globe la classique ce gamin et il y a
peut-être une dizaine de nouveaux les
idées pour les Noirs récemment
très souvent d'ailleurs introduites par
les par personne je sais ce qui me fait
plaisir avec cette ouverture c'est que
ça c'est une vraie ouverture de
championnats du monde non ah oui
espagnol
maintenant je prévois C6 E3 fois 5 et 7
final c'est ça ce que je trouve alors tu
sais que cette finale je me suis mis à
la jouer
avec les noirs avec plutôt des bons
résultats bah ça me tombe pas parce que
c'est une bonne finale en fait mais en
fait
la finale c'est après E3 fois F5 dam F3
fougez 6 c'est ça moi prendre
je prends et en réalité la première fois
que j'ai vu cette position j'étais
catastrophe avec le noir donc j'ai
appris j'ai appris de Baki en plus donc
bon là tu apprends des meilleurs et en
réalité elle est vraiment pas mal si si
ok je sais pas combien de temps je
passais à analyser cette position là
sûrement plus qu'une semaine peut-être
alors entre 10 jours et deux semaines et
je peux dire pas par une seule façon
cette finale est tout à fait jouable moi
ce qui est
ce qu'il faut se voir que il faut pas
toujours
croire à l'ordinateur non oui je vois à
moitié croire à moitié réfléchir toi
l'ordinateur se trompe assez souvent
donc par contre c'est plutôt milieu pour
moi parce que comme ça comme ça
je m'investis beaucoup plus moi-même
dans les analyses 5 ça veut dire que
après faut H4 il voit alors jouer fou
cette parce que après H-6 fois H4 x 5
les finales les moins intéressantes pour
le noir parce qu'avec le pion H6 c'est
un peu moins bien ouais parce que le fou
sur justice sera moins stable c'est pour
nos spectateurs donc elle va jouer au 7
bien sûr c'est bizarre qu'il a refusé la
finale non ou
pas non parce que en fait maintenant
après CDD il faut je sens il y a toute
myriade des idées pour le Nord carrément
ouais je peux te donner juste un exemple
bizarre
parmi les dernières mais archi bizarre
H6 je pense être
parce que c'est normal quand le pion sur
quand on revient avec le fou on se fait
manger ouais et pourtant elle est partie
classique
donc
c'est une énigme idée maintenant
dans cette variante là donc intéressant
à voir lesquelles il va choisir j'ai pas
vu une idée avec du cavalier A6
cavaliers
bizarre t'empêche un peu et cavaliers à
6 cavaliers c'est 7
sans le courage 6 fois 4 pour toujours
pas alors c'était
aujourd'hui alors après faute de trois
je provient plutôt petit rock je crois
que j'ai vu d'ailleurs cette idée pour
les gens qui nous suivent souvent dans
la partie entre soupe
le cavalier qui est venu une partie
mémorable gagnée par Katia qui nous a
donné la victoire dans le match il a
permis de gagner tu connais soupe
moi je préviens maintenant fou de toi
et maintenant je pense et soit tour E8
soit que le R5 tout de suite avec les
déco valeur mais peut-être d'abord pour
atteindre que l'adversaire
parce que Kevin figure-toi si il joue
pas que les deux moi maintenant
[Musique]
je comprends pas moi-même en fait ouais
mais c'est mais j'ai vu pas mal de
cavaliers H5 aussi attraper le fou mais
je suis étonné là quand même du choix de
niveau pour le moment où il a une idée
parce que c'est position là je les
trouve toujours assez cool pour les
Noirs personnellement bah écoute on est
tous en Florence c'est par les résultats
précédents qui ont eu avec quand on joue
une ligne oui ici
il y a quand même gagné un très bon
parti contre
donc je pense qu'il y a de bons
souvenirs
je me rappelle
tu vois n'est pas on en discutait hier
avec Baki aussi hier d'ailleurs il a eu
de très bons résultats quand même il est
devenu un très bon joueur de 4 5 et
d'espagnol ouais et il est quand même
aller fort dans l'espagnol contre le
meilleur spécialiste Magnus Carlsen et
Ding il est quand même un peu plus
fragile dans ces Espagnols que que
Magnus et je suis étonné qu'il soit pas
allé quand même une fois sur sur le
Marshall ou l'anti Marshall non pas quoi
ok car c'est le meilleur c'est vrai
mais jingle était quand même toujours
bien et il connaît toutes les faire
enfin toutes les finesses et les
canettes plein de finesse dans cette
Virtu et il a eu de très bons résultats
et en plus n'oublions pas depuis le
match contre Carson je pense mes potes
doit être
traumatisé d'aller dans ces Espagnols
tranquilles
doit être vraiment traumatisé parce que
là essayer essayer essayer rien de rien
n'a jamais marché
le problème c'est
réfuté quoi c'est ça le problème disons
il y a
les dimensions pratiques les dimensions
théoriques théoriques théoriquement
l'écossaise à ce moment-là donc
[Musique]
le 12 avril 2023 comme quoi
théoriquement il y a pas de
c'est dommage mais vous vous inquiétez
pas ceux qui adorent cette ouverture là
les nouveaux logiciels vont arriver et
ils vont faire marcher ils vont faire
marcher c'est comme ça que les échecs
progressent depuis quelques temps voilà
expliquer pourquoi si pas dans ce dos
le problème c'est que
une autre partie de Katia et le cavalier
va être sur des 5 6 les meilleurs cases
du cards par contre quand tu joues danse
après
le cavalier c'est vraiment sur E5 parce
que il y a plus de F6 je suis affaibli
je viens de dire c'était encore en
secret de Dieu quoi il y a quelques mois
mais maintenant c'est devenu les
connaissances générales
tout le monde sait enfin tout ce mec là
et moi aussi depuis quelques mois donc
c'est pour ça que dans ce dos donc dans
ce dos comme quoi neutralise le poème
basé sur
le point à ce nouveau d'ailleurs assez
récent mais assez logique
très très logique ma cavalière
[Applaudissements]
ouais ouais le cavalier de riz sur E5
est beaucoup plus efficace une fois le
pion noir est sur
mais tu sais ce que j'adore avec le
cavalier de pitbury
c'est que quand tu regardes les parties
de pilsbury il a juste essayé de battre
tout le monde en foutant son cavalier
sur 5 et son pion sur F4 mais j'adore en
fait c'est toute sa carrière sa courte
carrière malheureusement il l'a fait le
même plan quoi
d'ailleurs
je t'ai jamais le spécialiste de plus
Berry mais est-ce que avec le noir il a
essayé de faire les mêmes choses
toujours son cavalier sur E4
malheureusement j'ai pas l'impression
mais je peux pas dire parce que moi
j'étais fasciné donc j'ai regardé il est
parti avec les Blancs et il est il
entame toujours ce plan en fait dès
qu'il peut il fout son cavalier sur le 5
et son pire sur F4 quoi mais ça c'est
quelque chose qui manque dans les échecs
c'est que à cette époque là donc il y a
plus d'une centaine d'années on est
au début du 20e siècle c'était une
époque où chaque joueur avait son plan
et c'était vraiment une bataille de
style oui moi je pense que le cavalier 5
gagne et non mais déjà par exemple
avant le match pour le
souvent par exemple Stanis a publié ses
articles il faut jouer avec le noir
comme ça contre le Gambi devant
ses articles non de la merde en fait
c'est complètement réputé et tout et il
faisait ça avant le match contre le
Coran et puis pendant le match contre
ils ont essayé de prouver les causes
c'était beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus noble quoi que mangent
bah non c'est plutôt toi mais je trouve
ça génial ça donne une autre dimension
en fait mais ce serait idéologique
moi je te la fais marcher ouais tu joues
l'écossais si tu te fais réfuter mais ok
pendant cette partie tu continues il
faut d'ailleurs que en les impose à
refaire ça maintenant serait génial
ouais genre tu es obligé d'annoncer
avant le début du match ok je vais
défoncer ton Marshall de merde quoi
ouais ouais non je tiendrai ok vas-y
prouve ça avec stockfish vent et toi et
moi je vous prouverai ça avec le chat du
petit tu vois tu te mets sur la gueule
mais il y avait il y a une noblesse du
du combat
c'est très marrant et il faut aussi que
au lieu de ce Condens
officiellement
représente je crois 4G pitty Léo te
représente un autre réseau
et du coup ils se mettent sur la gueule
quoi pendant 14 parties
mais ça me fait penser c'était la phrase
de Bronstein ouais j'étais pas battu
j'ai battu ton style ouais ouais bien
sûr
[Musique]
un jour une seule partie au même temps
il faut que au même temps on joue 4
reparti et dans ces cas-là si tu as
perdu ou c'est pas parce que tu as
beaucoup un truc oubli un truc c'est
parce que ton style
non mais c'était plus amusant
est-ce que tu lisais les articles de
journaux avant tu sais pas trop le cas
la raison en fait c'était vraiment comme
comme
des quoi
[Musique]
[Rires]
ta mère c'est beau
[Musique]
mais tu pourras les articles de journaux
avant le match est-ce que ta mère va
faire tenir le gambit dame
[Rires]
[Musique]
j'ai battu ton arbre généalogique
[Rires]
[Musique]
non mais mieux j'ai des racines et ton
arme général
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est vrai que ça donnerait
ça donnerait des matchs beaucoup plus
de débat
et même génétiquement quoi
et chacun veut prouver qu'il a raison
mais
tiens d'ailleurs tu sais pourquoi le
premier match de championnat du monde a
commencé si tard
en 18 c'était 83 18 86 86 c'est le début
tu sais pourquoi on a attendu si
longtemps pour jouer le premier match de
championnat du monde parce que c'était
avant de les créations de sport
de ce milieu là et ce jour je pense que
l'idée ne lui aura pas Vignon avant je
vais préciser l'idée d'organiser un
match championnat du monde elle est
arrivée à peu près vers 1870 quelque
chose comme ça quelques années près mais
ils ont pas pu organiser le match avant
le milieu des années 80
pourquoi
tu peux trouver
10 après la retraite de Morphy c'est pas
tout à fait précis il y a quelqu'un qui
sait tribunal de police parce que morphi
était encore vivant et tant que morfi
était vivant il y avait personne qui
voulait
payer pour le match
intéressant même si la vérité des échecs
depuis presque une vingtaine d'années
et
pour le coup ça fait très mal à Zucker
parce que c'était le meilleur joueur du
monde à cette période là comme ça
malheureusement
mais ouais et du coup sur Carter il est
pas du tout resté dans l'histoire
personne ne le connaît quasiment alors
qu'il était hyper fort il était fort pas
possible lui
je sais pas si tu as dû regarder c'est
parti évidemment oh oui bien sûr
ce jeu enfin surtout je sais que leur
premier match a été architecte à Dieu et
le deuxième a été écrasé par instinite
tout simplement parce que le deuxième
est déjà dans 10 ans plus tard et
pendant ces 10 ans là
inventé son théorie positionnelle il a
crié tous les principes du jeu
positionnel les sales est permis de
montrer les différents
mais en gros zougart il adorait
son pion en C5
il a adoré ça mais je crois que dans une
partie qu'il a perdu en fait c'était
quelque chose un peu comme ça bon pas du
tout cette position mais il s'est pris
une partie connue où il s'est pris
cahier des 7 5 et il s'est fait défoncer
mais il a continué à jouer pour ses cinq
en fait il a pensé que l'espace était
hyper important
dommage pour lui
c'était pour un peu meublé un Vlad
écoute n'oublie mais à vrai dire c'est
le troisième partie déjà et je comprends
toujours pas du tout l'habitude de Ding
de réfléchir avant faire les cours qu'il
connaît c'est quoi les points de perdre
bientôt 10 minutes pour les coups que il
aurait pu faire un espace de quelques
secondes il va faire coller 5 maintenant
je suis complètement sur OK il y a une
autre ligne ici avec 5 etc mais je pense
que il est moins clair
pourquoi personne ne voulait payer juste
pour le match Zucker tort
c'est mal expliqué mais tant que morfié
était vivant personne ne voulait payer
parce que tout le monde considérait que
morfi était plus fort ce qui était vrai
ce qui était vrai
alors ok ton bête maintenant quand les
H5 ou pas
donc tu peux commencer avec A5
moi tu veux je veux dire ton bête c'est
plutôt que il va partir pour un point ou
pour l'autre
moi je serai parti pour B5
parce que en fait je dois dire que
l'ordinateur adore autant les pauses de
noir après F3 bassin oui que il commence
souvent par le coup A4 malgré les
établissements de sur B4 et malgré qu'il
y aura plus de plantes de l'attaque de
minorité mais il y a quasiment plus
personne qui fait l'attaque de minorité
dans cette position ah ouais c'est vrai
qu'il y a pas mal de méthodes contre
même que peut-être se réalisables
donc les questions maintenant les bons
jours à 4h mais j'adore ce plan avec les
noirs
alors que quand j'étais gamin on m'a
appris qu'il fallait absolument jamais
faire ça oui mais combien d'hôtels
n'existe plus maintenant alors que c'est
tellement fort
c'est sympa d'ailleurs et après B5 ce
qui est marrant mes chers amis
disons F3 bassin oui par exemple
le four voit presque jamais sur
Bruxelles
il voit soit sur A6 pour échanger
l'autre sur deux trois plus tard ou
cavalier B6 et sur Bruxelles presque
jamais c'est pour les infos générales
quoi
mais tu sais que je préfère quasiment
les Noirs maintenant dans cette position
bah les Noirs
les questions c'est les pose après
Jeanne raquette
intéressant et en plus il a joué
et il s'est levé instantanément après à
trois donc si vous voulez à trois c'est
c'est un très bon exemple d'un coup
précieux lactique
comme quoi alors les Noirs veulent
peut-être pas jouer B5 avant F3 F3
et sinon donc peut-être les Noirs
veulent pas faire ça
je vais deviner donc j'ai pas j'ai pas
vu
l'autre pense de jouer que relier c'est
un
et sinon
[Musique]
enfin c'est pas la première ligne
mais là ça devient la 3e mais cavaliers
B1 champion pour cavalier D2 et
peut-être comme tu as la case F3 qui est
libre car elle est F3 pour
e5bury
il aurait
en plus tu tapes sur toutes les cases
blanches
ça c'est quelque chose quand même pas
mal
[Rires]
il est vrai peut-être je déconnecte j'ai
parlé de A4 qui vient parce que pas dans
cette position le cavalier encore sur de
7 les Noirs aurait pu répondre sur A4
désolé je suis prêt de avouer que je
devais
8 tu reviens
à toi et si tu joues que vous lui fuite
A4 et écris que oui
[Musique]
je pense
ah non il m'a fait pardon
ok je connaissais les lignes
il est très intéressant ok il vit alors
qu'avolioca si je joue kawali
en gros c'est ça même si je suis en
train de simplifier et là pendant les
parties je pense que j'ai une super idée
parce que j'ai vérifié après avec
l'ordinateur elle est très bon qui vient
à trois
et maintenant tu menaces
l'ordinateur approuve mais
malheureusement je pense
t'as quand même gagné
je pense genre 2014 ventre comme ça tu
devais pas être bien
bah disons j'ai pas gagné moi j'ai une
excuse j'étais quand même grippé
sur cet exact position contre guéri en
2022 probablement une partie sur
Internet
le jour de la dame je me suis expliqué
très très détaillement sur l'une des
vidéos sur la chaîne vous pourrez revoir
te revoir très facilement ça a été très
détaillé comme les vidéos
j'ai une petite excuse je n'avais que
quatre ans
[Rires]
en tout cas il réfléchit non pas à trois
c'est très malin en fait il faut trouver
il faut trouver un coup quoi oui mais il
a déjà joué Ding donc il connaît
elle a déjà joué il a eu cette position
en 2022
et comme on est là
bien sûr normal et ok
je t'encule sur qu'est-ce qui se passe
d'habitude qui viennent après collège
et maintenant les Noirs jouent Jean j'ai
pas que les fuites
disons c'est un peu plus salé et
maintenant il y a deux points premiers
C1 et après F3 et deuxième peut-être
lui il peut revenir vers F2 ou E3 après
ouais plutôt que voler
c'est ça ce que ça donne d'habitude
tu peux pas entamer des F5 avec les
Noirs tu arrives pas du tout
non je pense que c'est
archi solide bien sûr
mais elle est bon
cette idée générale donc bon j'ai
analysé ça beaucoup
moins que les finales qui ont montré au
début de le retransmission et c'est très
très dur d'analyser ça très très dur
c'est très très c'est tellement détaillé
complexe tout
mais
jingle à vrai dire
avec chaque partie de plus en plus en
fait
il a vu cette pause il a eu ça dans sa
prépa et là il fait ça mais je sais pas
qui les Anne joindre
ce que il est en train de faire
maintenant je sais pas
elle était pas bien au niveau du temps
les dernières fois essayer il veut se
retrouver de la même situation ça
commence à être un peu trop hein
la ligne masochiste
c'est particulier ce qui fait mes choix
qu'il est juste pas la mentalement parce
que le fait d'avoir raté qui avait les
problèmes physiques dans la partie
précédente c'est quand même
bah écoute en général on se demande au
niveau comment il est venu même pas au
niveau de ouverture au niveau
d'ouverture les dernières fois ça allait
merveilleusement d'ailleurs mais
mentalement que moi mais il était arrivé
ce match là on se demande mais est-ce
que il est comment dire est-ce que il
sait il connaît
en général le concept du match qu'est-ce
que c'est le match quoi il est venu je
pars pour une promenade sur les
croisettes les vigno pour jouer un autre
tournoi est-ce qu'il comprend le concept
du match que c'est c'est un duel c'est
une bagarre et et c'est compliqué et
tout parce que il y a sur chaque
conférence de presse de son sort j'ai
pas l'hôtel n'est pas que le bon enfant
je me sens pas bien du tout bah tu es
venu pour te bagarrer bagarrer tu veux
que je te montre un piège marrant ouais
genre si elle fait fouger 3
cavalier
5 pouces et 7 je pense comme ça
il faut avoir une fois
si je me trompe pas et abonne-toi tu
dois pas être bien
tout de suite et puis donc dingue va
encore se plonger dans les réflexion
pendant 10 minutes très facile de
prévoir ce que va nous arriver
c'est beau quand même qu'une des
conclusions de népo après son match
contre carlsheim c'est qu'il faut garder
le bide
[Rires]
et tu t'imagines elle gagne
l'adversaire et dans la cérémonie de
couverture et il faut la danse du ventre
quoi je pensais encore plus beau comme
dans les Risto Maroc
d'ailleurs j'aurais beaucoup payé pour
voir la danse du ventre
je n'ai pas de ne pas j'aurais payé
généreusement la feed va lui payer un
million deux pour pouvoir
le virement un million de quoi
[Musique]
il commence à tenir
[Rires]
les deux sont assez je pense qu'ils ont
reçu quelques critiques de la part des
officiels ils sont beaucoup plus assis
aujourd'hui ah ouais d'ailleurs c'est
visible peut-être qu'on leur a dit que
c'était un peu trop quoi
ils ont décalé une caméra pour qu'on ait
l'impression qu'il soit assis tous les
deux
un peu plus longtemps
il connaît encore Yann évidemment là il
essaye juste de se rappeler
rien de quoi se rappeler en fait
de toute manière je pense pour réaliser
le point F3 E4 de toute manière tu dois
déplacer ta tour sur un et
les autres cours enfin dans des deux
pour l'instant de l'espace de jouer F3
de toute manière donc tu commences après
tu reviens et puis tu choisis l'un de
deux plans par contre j'aime bien la
proposition de l'ordi il faut acheter
trois
et maintenant
et là tu fais
un dériver original de varier
non pas du tout original en fait c'est
la grosse classique c'est pour de
l'histoire de toucher ton adversaire à
gauche à droite pour donner de la bouffe
mentale ton équipe
pour voir donc qu'est-ce qu'il a
dans son slip quoi
[Musique]
c'est vraiment là il est vraiment dans
la mémoire il essaie de revoir son
fichier intellectuellement
tu penses ça peut être autre chose que
tout ravin ou il essaye de se rappeler
du coup d'après déjà non
je pense il essaie de se rappeler
comment les lignes vont parce que je
pense pas que ça tendait trop à ce qu'on
voit maintenant je pense pas et donc il
s'est dit donc tiens ok
alors comment exactement et c'est quoi
ou peut-être par exemple il a eu se pose
sans toi
cinq et peut-être il est en train de
comprendre c'est quoi le de
différence attends aucune idée en fait
ah parce que lion de différence
peut-être quand tu joues ma chambre ça
peut être que le noir auront peut-être
une pas ici par exemple que vous voulez
par exemple ça peut être que le noir
auront l'option de jeu pas B6 fois par
exemple juste comme je dis que juste
comme ça peut-être je dis sûrement une
connerie mais c'est possible pour donner
un exemple où je sais pas qu'est-ce que
ça donne c'est les Noirs poussent de 5
de 4 ici
tu vois parce que non pas ici
j'ai voulu faire qualitien mais ça ça a
pas fait ce que je voulais ouais
peut-être ça fait c'est quoi les
différences en fait
après il peut juste cliquer un coup au
hasard on va juste pour un cavalier
d'air et voilà si tu veux cliquer un
coup au hasard tu peux toujours faire
wash sauf que après avoir change on se
pose que le point avec cavalier DX peut
devenir plus intéressant pour le noir ah
oui la Clique droit
c'est presque 10 minutes
de penser plus que 15 minutes de jeu ce
n'est pas ils ont dépensé 20 et 15
donc les deux sont là pensif qu'à moi
pour arriver à la position que en
général les deux doivent qu'en être pas
mal allez doivent être encore pas mal de
théorie enfant
les plantes sourds quelques femelles
sur aussi mais peut-être des variantes
[Musique]
concrètes
pas trop sûr ils suivent toujours la
partie dinguerie
c'est une question
non ça c'est Mohamed Nasser contre
Marwan Aboudi maintenant
je l'ai pas mais je pourrais trouver si
tu veux
bah vas-y
je peux trouver
une manipulation pouvait faire chier
vous aussi si vous souhaitez récupérer
les PGM des parties sur chasse comme ça
c'est assez pratique
est beau quand même
oh
oui mais pas autant que ça je pense on
regardera après
pour vous dire
quel est le problème avec DL6 en fait
c'est que après que
les bons vont faire F3 et il y a un gros
problème avec G4 c'est ça en fait
donc en général le cavalier se refite
souvent bien placé parce que il est
souple ça rend les positions noirs
souples tu penses que la partie
d'aujourd'hui va être longue ou que ça
va être soit digne fait n'importe quoi
hyper vite soit il réussit à solidifier
et ça va simplifier ok malheureusement
pour lui aujourd'hui il joue avec les
Noirs quoi que peut-être c'est pas si
malheureux parce que peut-être
mais pour il est plus comme avant c'est
complètement clair il s'est changé donc
maintenant il cherche à jouer à fond et
c'est pas que moi en fait qui a eu cette
impression c'est ici Pinko qui a
dit ça dans l'interview que maintenant
n'est pas comme pas comme avant il joue
à fond toutes les parties jusqu'à la fin
aller en star de personnes
donc
chez qui a presque arrivé dans les deux
premiers partis donc je pense que bien
sûr ne pas essayer à fond aujourd'hui
pour tuer l'adversaire mais il va pas se
permettre d'être de risque parce qu'il
m'aime déjà le score et qu'il a pas
besoin donc si l'enfonce le clou c'est
bien mais si ce n'est pas la peine pas
la peine donc en gros il voit essayer de
ce qu'on appelle masser son adversaire
faire un petit massage
et voilà ce que votre arrivée
aujourd'hui je suis plus mention
made in il peut réussir à aplanir la
position assez rapidement aussi si je
joue bien
on va faire quoi aplanir ça veut dire
aplanir ça veut dire rendre la position
plate non non bien sûr Dingo normalement
aujourd'hui il veut donc face à cette
partie
heureusement pour lui il y avait un jour
de réponse c'est très important
peut-être quand même il a eu son nom
[Musique]
d'ailleurs ce dernier tome là je préfère
le thé blanc je pense que c'est encore
plus fin et donc peut-être il a eu du
temps de se refaire
en France c'est un très très grand
joueur donc c'est vrai que il est
intéressant pas
trop trop trop
on va voir on va voir ce qu'il joue
normalement est-ce cavalier fuite c'est
le coup logique c'est le coup qui aille
jouer contre Giri c'est vrai qu'il aura
jeté quasiment 20 minutes on va dire à
la poubelle quoi
ça je comprenais très jamais par contre
par contre
quand tu as une grosse prépa
je pense c'est et ton adversaire suit
les lignes oui je pense que c'est toute
la vie je pense c'est une bonne idée de
passer pas mal du temps avant en faire
tes cours pour cacher que tu as une
grosse bombe entièrement en fait je fais
ça très souvent et ça m'a pas ramené pas
mal de résultats en fait parce que ton
adversaire il réfléchi sur toi elle
pense que son bons son cochon dangereux
moi est-ce qu'il suit encore ses
connaissances et une fois ton adversaire
arrive dans les positions critique tu
fais le coup vital avec une grosse
confiance et
tu sors
[Musique]
je te dribbler je t'ai eu jeté donc
écrasé je vais t'écraser
pour le moment il se passe pas grand
chose
l'ouverture est jouée mais je vais
repars là qu'on suit simplement les
coups d'une autre partie 40 minutes de
jeu quand même déjà vlades
et toujours rien de nouveau donc la
guerre psychologique la guerre des
tranchées
ils sont tous les deux barrés
ça y est on a enfin quelque chose de
plus habituel on a des pots qui revient
déjà
tranquillement
d'ailleurs je suis en train de me poser
une question tu connais un petit peu
Mario ou pas bah presque pas tu connais
Bowser
Bowser non
ils ont fait des des bottes des
ordinateurs avec des images de profil de
joueurs d'échec
et Bose ils l'ont fait house
ils ont fait Hikaru tu vois pas oser il
est d'accord que ce serait bien plutôt
nain aux heures que c'est plutôt de nepo
non
quelques sortes
de mon travail quelques dessins comme il
connaît pas je peux j'imagine que sur
twitch vous connaissais oula
c'est plutôt des pots non pas en quelque
sorte
non mais peut-être elle veut le dire que
sa gueule est aussi agressive que c'est
le dos nocaro
ce n'est pas
enfin oui
il est revenu un peu comme ça quoi sur
l'échiquier je sais pas si tu l'as vu
mais
on peut tranquille quoi
bon maintenant alors
il va suivre les pas de guéri où il va
sortir quelque chose de nouveau
je dois vous dire que en fait même si
jingle déjà eu cette position dans sa
carrière c'est normal que peut-être de
toute manière n'est pas archi bien
préparé ici parce que tu peux pas tout
préparer c'est juste c'est pas possible
il y a trop de choses je sais et en plus
ces derniers années
le nombre de parties se multipliées
encore
les rapides les Blitz les parties sur
Internet ou pas les classiques donc tu
peux pas tout préparer donc ça a été
alors cavalier c'est
dans sa partie contre contre
il a eu sur une partie comme ça déjà
donc ça donne pas trop dans le vide je
voulais de jouer que
ok essayons de comprendre qu'est-ce qui
se passe après que les dents alors je
pensais plus logique je pense que c'est
normal quoi
alors il y a pas de business parce que
plus de questions que
tu as fermé
donc F3 arrive déjà
c'est pour ça qu'il a effectué F6 ou
cavalu aussi d'avant je sais pas F3
après quoi l'autre a joué dans
enfin tous les coups sont très logique
bien sûr mais ça ça se voit que ça va
aller pour les noirs
normalement bien sûr les faiblesse
beaucoup parlé du Pione
pour les points
ok ça peut turquoise
ok bien sûr il y a de tels.com
tu penses qu'il a ok pourquoi pas je
pense
la position notre solide dans ce cas là
ok même si quelqu'un n'a préparé quelque
chose bon ok
ce sera un coup intéressant mais sans
plus quoi voilà c'est les spécificité
des
Espagnols classiques et de Gambie de
dames classique c'est pour ça que on les
appelle ces deux ouvertures les les
ouvertures des jours
parce que c'est solide un pur se tromper
il est clair mais ça ramène pas de
conséquences
mortelles tandis que les
Siciliens c'est une autre chose allez tu
peux te faire planter tu peux te faire
transpercer là tu peux pas au pire tu
fais une faute il faudra encore te
battre quand même
et quoi écouter je prévois nul
aujourd'hui
c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle pour
l'intérêt du match c'est le cas sur je
prévois aujourd'hui je pars
est-ce que avec beaucoup d'événements au
patron moi je prévois que aujourd'hui ça
va être plutôt une partie classique
plutôt peinard
et plutôt nul vers
vers le coup 35 par répétition
j'étais tranquille j'étais peinard à
jouer mon gambidame
et il a bu son café noir
et les jouets sont collés
[Rires]
viens on va en salle de repos
je lui ai dit laisse mes pions quoi
vous êtes pour qui vous d'ailleurs pour
qui voilà je suis pour le suspense pour
Ding mais avant avant le match
de conférence
moi bien sûr je suis pour Ding parce que
même
contre carcène
pour dire NON je suis d'accord
et le Clair numéro 2 mondial
avec lui lundi et il a dit qu'il était
loin d'être sûr que Carlsen le batit
facilement que ça s'il y avait un match
retour
en cours encore plus violent
pas quel numéro
3 quoi bah c'est vrai que on parle les
investissements et que il est où
il est un numéro de Michael
j'aime bien quand même qu'ils aient mis
les pif en fond
pardon j'aime bien qu'ils aient mis les
pif en fond
ça c'était vraiment une belle trouvaille
je trouve ça vraiment
bien et c'est bien cadré en plus regarde
tu as vraiment regarde les pots regarde
quand il est pas là tu as vraiment le
pif quoi mais les billes dorés étaient
meilleurs quand même
bah pour ne pas oui pour Ding ça aurait
été un peu décevant bah bien
[Musique]
peut-être tu mets deux fois le but de ne
pas rire
[Rires]
une grosse pression
faut que j'organise un match contre
Maxime biyaji mais tu dois pas le
connaître mais il a aussi un beau pif
quoi qui est le deuxième second voie bah
justement c'est ça ce que fait le
marrant c'est que depuis quelques années
combien il y a pas de numéro en fait
enfin depuis que wanna
il a quand même gagné de manière très
convaincante les deux derniers candidats
mais qui est numéro 2 personne personne
et comme ça pendant encore longtemps
il y a quelques années
[Rires]
[Musique]
tout le temps le sourire oui bien sûr il
est incroyable
tu es tout de suite heureux c'est un il
est incroyable parmi il a une énergie
fantastique non j'ai vu autant de
tendance de La Doré pendant le bus 15
si vous voulez moi un peu tourner la
tête quoi
mais carrément un peu tourner la tête
quand j'ai appris ça au début je pouvais
pas y croire en fait
ego cash
c'est tellement top d'en parler même on
peut parler de Google je peux parler
d'un gosse de 9 ans je sais pas mais
qu'est-ce que le problème dans sa vie
on sait pas quoi
c'est difficile pour le moment de
l'imaginer en finale de championnat du
monde là c'est un peu difficile on
espère qu'il revienne mais c'est là il
est loin maintenant
bon je pense que tout le monde en fait
il y a encore un creux qui s'est fait
[Musique]
[Rires]
un peu moins pire
est-ce que guéri peut progresser ça
c'est une bonne question
aux échec oui mais pas mentalement
parce que très souvent et d'ailleurs
j'en ai parlé avec pas mal de joueurs de
Lead disons que ok ces connaissances
devient de mieux au milieu il est il est
comment il a perdu quelques fois blesses
faiblesse purement échiquier que il a eu
avant et il en a perdu au moins le
problème c'est que psychologiquement il
reste toujours plus ou moins le même
j'ai l'impression trop souvent quand les
gagnants tu as l'impression qu'ils
cherchent tout à faire pour ne pas
gagner et d'ailleurs de ce point de vue
il est carrément l'héritier de l'écho
parce que avec Peter malheureusement
c'était bien ça
très souvent donc on a eu l'impression
nous tous les 50 ans on a d'ailleurs
Peter que au lieu de gagner il préférait
faire
[Rires]
tu peux d'ailleurs deviner
ce que pourquoi
[Musique]
quelle est la raison d'après moi
tu dois savoir d'après moi les raisons
d'être très sympa
si tu pouvais ou si tu gagnes et en plus
si tu gagnes brillamment très possible
que cette nuit tu vas pas dormir
normalement tu vois être complètement
déstabilisé alors si tu fais une petite
nulle ça va ça passe
ça casse pas ça passe
et tu vois regarde il y a quelqu'un qui
revenait sur notre conversation quand tu
as pas réussi deux trois fois et tu vois
il t'a écrit comment il sait et le kappa
tu vois c'est celui que je t'ai montré
ce matin comment il sait et il fait la
tête Kappa
ça ça veut rien dire mais
j'ai pas compris comment pourquoi après
la phrase comment elle sait il y a qu'à
pas en fait c'est comment tu sais que si
tu as pas réussi deux trois fois ça
devient pénible
tu vois regarde ils sont très heureux tu
as le cafard peu intervenir à tout
moment pour ajouter un effet comique
il faut dire il est beau
mais sinon dans les villes
on va nous dire mais je crois que c'est
quelqu'un qui a programmé le site pour
une raison X ou Y ils l'ont mis en émote
de test et il est devenu
hyper connu mais il est connu d'accord
mais sinon il est aimé ou de tester au
moquer ou moi il a de les gens l'adore
hein d'accord je pense que les gens
l'adorent il est devenu mythique
ouais tu vois c'est un employé twitch
c'est une fantôme de lui ouais c'est
juste une ils ont juste mis la photo au
hasard pour faire une émote pour faire
des tests sur twitch et c'est resté quoi
à noter que ce n'est pas son record
d'élo à
2799.8 ça veut dire que si gagne une
partie il passe pour la première fois
au-dessus de 2800
pardon si une époque gagne une partie
pas il passera pour la première fois
au-dessus des 2800 il en avait jamais
le deuxième bah écoutez
bande de gens qui à un moment donné
passer 2008 déjà même Nakamura
et tu penses quoi d'ailleurs du retour
de Nakamura est-ce qu'il y a un vrai
retour
mondial là oui mais c'est pas le vrai
retour il était le deuxième moi je pense
ou pas alors attends je pense pas qu'on
peut un peu parler du vrai retour
ah d'accord
donc écoutez
avant dans cette position là il y a déjà
joué que 6
il le fait toujours pas depuis peut-être
plus que 10 minutes je sais pas
qu'est-ce qu'il fabrique parce que à
part cela bon si pas que les 6 alors
qu'est-ce que les noirs peuvent faire
peut-être alors les noirs peuvent jouer
fou E6 avec des idées de mettre la tour
sur celui de quelque chose de ce genre
d'ailleurs quand vous mettez le fou sur
E6 l'une des idées qu'il noir peut
réaliser ce b65 plus tard d'ailleurs
parce que le noir défend en avance le
pion sur 200 qui va être République par
cette poussée depuis Henri j'y crois pas
trop en fait même pas du tout à vrai
dire mais c'est juste pour
essayer d'expliquer les choses donc à
part de fou E6 que veulent 6
à vrai dire je vois presque pas d'autres
cours mais si c'est possible
les deux pions en même temps mais
peut-être à un peu les positions noirs
donc j'y crois pas trop
voilà sinon oui j'ai oublié peut-être ça
donne pas trop d'envie mais il y a un
point aussi avec justice que vous voulez
je sais il faut F5 oh ouais le classique
du
comment s'appelle ce verset du cambrid
Spring où ils te font cavalier de 7
cavaliers F8 G6 qui a eu 6 kg 7 x 5 et
le plan ridicule d'ailleurs et encore
pas mal de modifications de ce point y
compris ce que tu as dit non je suis
tout à fait possible en fait et après 3
après 3
un bref 3 donc si Corée je sais il y a
au 4 alors et là c'est pas bien donc
peut-être alors pas que les jeux c'est
tout de suite non justice F3 et
peut-être dans des six ou quelque chose
de ce genre là au moins ça stoppe E4
pour l'instant et après tu veux
peut-être que je sais il faut 5 enfants
guérit était juste très bien pourquoi
s'embêter bref
ce qu'il a peur parce qu'il a peur de
son ombre parce qu'en fait son plan il
est juste hyper logique cavalier mal
placé tu le remets ok l'autre s'il veut
prétendre pour quelque chose il va
devoir te faire F3 tu fous ton Cavaillon
aussi c'est interdit aux quatre il va
mettre ça dans F2 pour défendre enfin je
vois pas où peut être le problème
fondamental de cette position
il y a un seul problème fantôme mental
de pourquoi
c'est ça le problème
d'ailleurs
je sais pas
il est en psychologue dans son équipe ou
non mais c'est étonnant parce que
pourquoi tu te casses la tête autant que
ça tu as joué une partie demande à ta
maman
si elle nous écoute elle doit nous
écouter
Nadine Nadine s'il te plaît
oui fais quelque chose
ne pas trop intéressant sinon on a dit
s'il te plaît il faut faire ouais non là
c'est sûr que c'est un vrai problème
Vlad
ouais c'est trop là ok peut-être un
petit bruit alors parce qu'il va encore
chercher
un premier colis
ça va être le moment de faire le break
et au moins on va faire le café on va
revenir avec plein d'énergie mais c'est
vrai que si on réfléchit bien il y a une
heure de jeu bon il sait pas on a pu
raconter des choses mais c'est rien
passé encore
j'adorais les vagues madding
bravo bravo
tu imagines c'est une heure de jeu et il
s'est enfin il s'est rien passé on a eu
le choix de l'ouverture etc c'est
intéressant mais là ça fait bien une
demi-heure que la partie est bloquée
juste
juste bloquer
est-ce qu'il a peur de rejouer une
partie déjà joué de répéter une partie à
jouer oui probablement mais oui oui non
c'est les réponses c'est les réponses
oui
il a peur de la prépa mythique même si
en fait je pense pas qu'il y a trop de
prix pas de toute façon c'est une
position enfin je vais juste remontrer
la position c'est quand bien même nepo
il aurait encore un coup là ou deux
coups là il va pas il va pas tu vas pas
perdre en un coup de là oui tu as peur
de bouffer avec la dame bouffe avec le
chemin
si tu veux
ça peut pas être trop grave ça en fait
la position elle est saine pour les
noirs
de la part de Ding Yann Soul a lieu pour
nous c'est ça son envie pressant pour
que finalement que force de partir
il ose finalement à faire son cours en
fait non mais c'est fou tu imagines il
vient il vient il a vraiment mis à la
poubelle allez on va pas dire 40 minutes
mais au moins 25
juste et il a perdu 25 minutes de
concentration 25 minutes de tout pour
rien quoi
l'envie d'aller aux chiottes
il rappelle Fiero candina c'est vrai ça
rappelle un peu ce qu'a fait firuja
quand il a craqué
à des moments pour rien quoi faut dire
quand vous réfléchissez longtemps vous
perdez pas que du temps mais vous perdez
aussi de la concentration de la force
pour plus tard
non le problème c'est que ok n'est pas
Fischer d'accord bien sûr même s'il
n'est pas assez cher bien sûr le
comportement de son adversaire les dons
beaucoup plus de confiance et c'est ça
le problème aussi c'est pas que vous
diminuez votre niveau si vous augmentez
le niveau de l'autre bah tu fais les
deux en même temps ouais c'est ça et le
pire en fait
c'est des vases communicants
en anglais
[Rires]
au boulot au boulot sors des chiottes
ce match là va sur moi rester les pires
miroirs mémoire de Ding pour le reste de
sa vie quoi non mais là c'est trop
cavalier et en plus ce n'est pas même
s'il a aucune prépa c'est que l'autre
Philippe il va juste tout lui envoyer
c'est trop ce qu'il fait
[Musique]
hyper tout seul en réalité là
il a peur en fait
ne pas pour son comportement
[Musique]
il faut regarder son titre je pense
après il a pas de titre ah tu as de
grands
tu veux le punir bah oui mais ne bois
pas tu vas encore plus avoir envie
tu as même pas le droit à poursuivre
quoi
arrête quoi
non il faut qu'il boit du lait en poudre
[Rires]
qu'est-ce que tu aimes quoi ah c'est
trop
contenter les bouteilles d'eau quoi
ce serait beau qui est une époque ils
disent ne boit pas la bouteille j'ai
pissé dedans
[Rires]
n'a pas ne pas les trait de le faire si
on en va pas beau
mais peut-être juste par plaisir
[Musique]
[Rires]
derrière dis que regarde c'est
magnifique quoi
de de partir mécaniquement et vous
barrer la route peut-être non
[Musique]
il se refoulent pendant 10 minutes mais
quoi il pense lui en fait ah mais il est
fou là juste
ah mais il est juste fou pas possible en
fait
les réalités
je sais même pas quoi rajouter en fait
mais c'est incroyable il est il est
détruit mentalement un tel point
oui c'est vrai que comme a dit tolsto
les pires les forteresse ce sont les
forteresses mentales
il faut tout le boulot en fait et là il
perd juste tout ça et comme ça depuis
trois parties déjà
il a tellement l'air au fond du trou que
j'ai peur qu'il tombe dans la cuvette
des chiottes
[Rires]
[Musique]
le candidat pour le titre champion et
mystérieusement
[Rires]
le police
on a retrouvé Ding dans les eaux usées
[Rires]
c'est trop
cool
[Rires]
[Musique]
oh là là
non mais c'est triste en fait il est
toujours pas rentré dans le match nous
on rigole parce qu'on a rien à faire
mais il est toujours pas rentré dans le
match c'est les premières fois je pense
que depuis peut-être 40 minutes je
commente avec les larmes dans les yeux
profondeur
[Rires]
il va juste arriver avec son vide dans
mes feuilles
et l'autre il va dire il a encore
préparé pendant 10 secondes
j'adore la conférence de presse c'était
quoi votre prépa je sais pas je me
rappelle juste la partie
c'est trop regarde
des cours
c'est trop regarde il est juste à
regarder il comprend pas quoi ah
non mais faut qu'il revienne et qui
fasse de la meuf de la tempo ça va être
trop beau
mais vite quoi dépêche quoi viens faire
le taf 2
c'est incroyable
pourquoi ce drôle que va réussir ça bah
que pour une seule raison en fait c'est
parce que jingle cette position contre
guérit il y a un homme
mais pourtant pour y arriver le dépenser
alors
presque 50 minutes bah c'est pour ça que
c'est drôle
quelqu'un nous fait noter que après dame
[Musique]
oui pourquoi pas
mélangé sa partie en fait il dit guérit
en gros a dit que ce qu'il a joué là
avec les Blancs c'était pas terrible
Iris qui commence
bon si Dame est pas top que bien
probable de toute façon mais pour n'a
pas trop d'idées dans cette position
c'est juste que les citer les coups en
fait comme il faut souvent dans sa
carrière
un peu jeune de deux
pourquoi bah juste pour attendre
peut-être un jour jouer quand même
EU4 et surtout attendre
vous savez en fait dans ces positions là
parfois il existe le point avec pas avec
E4 mais avec F4
[Musique]
des trois cavaliers
je suis en train de chercher quoi faire
pour les bons si un vieux évitez alors
donc les parties de guéri contre
ridicule
[Musique]
numéro 1 cavalier 1 2 1 2 coups numéro 2
pour gagner cette partie de toute façon
j'ai pu j'ai besoin de rien donc je joue
dans des deux et après je joue à champ
et puis le mec tombe autant quoi
tu suis les préceptes de spaski si ton
adversaire a fait une erreur attends il
va en faire encore une plus grosse voilà
en réalité c'est un coup très logique
parce que ça protège des quatre de
manière directe ça protège le 1 ça
prépare 4 et après E4 éventuellement ici
les dames ne pas sur
par exemple oui je sais pas dame de deux
là dans quelque part ce qui est
important que après E42 les cases F4
défendu aussi parce que souvent c'est ça
le problème avec les poussins souvent
pas forcément ici par contre si après
dame de deux les Noirs font le point
avec B6 fois 6 là
mais donc il propose sur dame F2 B5
qui est toujours possible
surtout quand grâce aux cavaliers sur E6
votre case sur ce 5 bien blender
voilà
sinon parlant de dingue vous savez en
fait je peux vous partager avec vous
certaines informations que je connais
sur lui
qui ont Mortas m'a raconté que en fait
son parcours aux échecs un petit peu
bizarre comme quoi il est très bien
commencé
en tant que juniors
il était très connu à l'âge de 14 ans un
truc comme ça peut-être 16 ans je sais
pas
et donc Mokhtar l'a vu au championnat du
monde junior dans une de ces deux
catégorie et puis il est complètement
disparu complètement d'espérant à un
apparu jouer elle n'a pas vu dans les
championnats du monde avant 18 ans avant
18 ans etc il était resté chaud
et tout d'un coup il a ouvert la porte
il me semble
il est sûr finalement
et on l'a revu ouais non mais on va dire
un truc sérieux et là retourné et le
écrasé avec un très petit héros par
rapport au standard du championnat de
France de de de la Chine et le retourner
il a écrasé le championnat de Chine
adulte écrasé avec un petit rougeur 2004
60 quelque chose comme ça donc
c'est pour dire que c'est pas que les
bizarres pendant ce match son parcours
est bizarre
en tout cas il a juste rejouer les mêmes
coups que contre Ding et plutôt Yann qui
a fait n'importe quoi en réalité
[Musique]
jusqu'à présent a été très très pratique
il a donc comment dire et il a profité
que son adversaire s'est rendu au un peu
fou pour dépenser autant du temps à mon
arrivée à la position qu'il connaît donc
maintenant il est en train de donc
décider quelle décision pratique prendre
parce que je m'embête il va pas jouer
dans
quel coiffeur il doit décider maintenant
je pense s'il donne sa langue corporelle
il va prendre les décisions très vite
la E2
visage au secours
est plus protégé oui et à part de E4 il
est Redemption de mettre son câble sur
je trouve
ça peut être ça prépa cavalier E2 mais
pour ne pas connu pour réfléchir au
temps du temps pendant que il joue son
prépa il n'est pas caillou pour ça
et il est il est cailloux pour j'ai pas
quand il cite il cite ses connaissances
sur sur le pendule qui avant le parti
donc si
il est il a fait ça à L'Express que je
sais pas c'est plus du tout mais pour
que
je suis le truc logique et normal
si tu joues B5 ça me donne la vie do
n'est pas jouer E4 mode de jeu
ne me demande pas pourquoi je dise comme
ça au feeling
maintenant je suppose soit que le dos
soit
je pense que ici je peux espérer un
petit quelque chose
j'ai pas combien mais je sens que ça
doit être un petit peu mieux pour le bon
[Musique]
pourtant ça me paraît pas impressionnant
quand même mais ouais
mais
dans cette ouverture en fait c'est dur
d'impressionner
mais oui c'est une position très
compliquée évidemment surtout
très solide
et ici impressionné c'est pas donné
parfois tu peux pas arriver
impressionner
pendant j'ai pas de dix ans de partie
c'est juste c'est tellement
tellement solide pour les Noirs à la fin
du compte parce que aussi un vrai garde
attentivement en fait le noir ils n'ont
pas de faiblesse en fait
aucune ça veut dire que les blancs
doivent alors dresser à un point à très
long terme pour réussir quelque chose
parce que on ne peut pas juste viser une
faiblesse il y en a pas
il faut l'écrire encore donc si vous
voulez le débat stratégie que il vient
d'être lancé F3 te rend que les deux et
vos voilà mais sinon la position n'est
pas déstabilisée l'impression n'est pas
disponible
et sinon si tu veux éviter
au 4 les Noirs appartient
je pense que j'ai pas mal coup je peux
aller sur
d'ailleurs c'est le coup que je préfère
j'ai pas trop peur de fou je suis en
fait
d'accord désolé
[Musique]
bah ok je peux vous faire dans de
je n'ai pas peur de ce temple
peut-être la dame mieux et là ok je suis
je sais d'ailleurs après
parce que si je veux réussir quand H4 x
5 etc je peux facilement
le cavalier à la fin du compte peut être
très mal pour
d'ailleurs je pense que quelqu'un très
fort au moins un temps très pratique on
se passe qui aurait pu faire dames
uses
ou un mec comme Ding peut réfléchir 25
minutes faire damber dmd8 aussi mais
avec l'idée sur cavalier j'ai trois pas
du tout G6 en fait juste un coup au
hasard d'ailleurs tu t'imagines si tu es
un joueur de chèque machin mais pourtant
tu fais aller à Bruce Lee l'herbite va
te dire quelque chose ou pas
alors attends on fait la petite pause
on fait la pause
à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on est de retour alors il s'est passé il
s'est pas passé grand chose pendant
qu'on est on s'est absenté une dizaine
de minutes il a joué il a joué ses cinq
en réalité il vient de passer une heure
pour rejouer exactement les mêmes
couples qu'on dirait par contre
juridique
là qui ont été absent je pense qu'une
chose très grande dépassée parce que il
est mis 50 minutes pour arriver à la
posture
il n'a pas réfléchi encore une heure
pour faire
par rapport à ce standard aujourd'hui
ou hier je sais pas cette fois-ci il
réagit assez vite
mais c'est complètement incohérent ce
qu'il fait c'est-à-dire qu'il réfléchit
très longtemps pour répondre
jesk du début le retour aurait pu voir
avoir maintenant
150 minutes sur sa pendule 110
une heure 50 minutes c'est 110 minutes
donc
quoi alors maintenant
j'imagine trop logique
et si pas tour de 8 et si je joue au
foot c'est si grave que ça
peut te prendre tu peux pas prendre du
cheval ou de la dame
[Musique]
moi non plus j'avais pas vu c'est l'ordi
c'est peut-être même pas si grave mais
bon tu as pas envie de le laisser mais
juste pour D8 en fait moi je trouvais
que ça avait l'air propre comme coup
parce que ce fou en baissant qu'est-ce
qu'il est bien placé je suis loin d'être
sûr
oh oui
là ça me donne envie de rejouer mon coup
préféré c'est Dame de deux alors
et puis peut-être je suis en train de
préparer quelque chose qu'on relève 4
maintenant du coup
ça c'est faux
je sais pas ça me fait tellement pas
peur en fait cette position là peut-être
alors je vais essayer pas
si je sais quelque chose comme
ouais non non je viens de dire
et maintenant il faut des 7
prises est attirée cavalière 4
c'est vrai que dans ce position là quand
on est sur un 5 à chaque fois il faut
qu'on saisir ce coup c'est Adam elle est
bien placé quand même quoique bon ok je
joue tout raciste
je perdue au point tour
je bouffe
et là une grosse question pour toi ah
yes
ça me force de jouer damophobe c'est que
un petit peu de agréable même si c'est
pas la fin du monde non plus
il savait qu'il allait faire ses 5 quand
même et non bien sûr que non
mais après tour D8 down de 2
qui est logique finalement avec tout ce
qu'on a vu c'est il fait juste baisser
exactement ce que c'est exactement ce
que je voulais
ça c'est logique comme ça surprise tu
pourras prendre du pion et là tu as plus
de problème en fait avec les noirs
non moi une fois les bandes prennent sur
ce 5 les Noirs reprennent sur ce 5 c'est
très facile de devenir moins bien ma vie
si tu peux vraiment être mieux avec les
Noirs là et tout ça ça vient du pion F3
parce que quand on va jouer la structure
des pions pendant le pion en F3 il est
très mal placé
et ça
peut créer plus de fait
quand les Noirs vont posséder quatre
parce que une fois le centre s'ouvre le
roi faible le roi blanc peut devenir
faible non mais donc donc en réalité
tour D8 Dame des deux B6 c'est hyper
logique si tu comprends ça c'est hyper
logique c'est pas dur
une fois ça arrive sur le position tu es
même favori avec les noms je vais dire
que
nepo va se calmer mais ne peut voir
comment c'est de la position
avec les Blancs
et peut-être je vois gagner mon pari à
ceux qui n'ont pas été il y a une
demi-heure
je peux vous dire que j'ai fait un pari
comme quoi donc ça va être match nul sur
le 35e couple par la répétition
j'ai essayé on va voir
bon mais il va quand même réfléchir bien
une demi-heure pour trouver ça à nos
écrits
comment c'est possible on est en direct
pourquoi au troisième feeling
ils me font peur
c'est pas possible
non
désolé bon ok pas grave
vous faites jamais confiance on sait on
ne vous fait pas confiance d'ailleurs
bravo non plus
[Musique]
ouais je sais pas c'est dommage pour
Ding d'avoir fait autant n'importe quoi
avec les Blancs parce qu'en fait il
aurait fait nul juste et il refait nul
là il était bien dans le match
ah ouais ouais bien sûr c'est bête en
fait ce qu'il a fait vraiment mais
je pense pourquoi est-ce que il est
autant déconné dans les parties
pressantes c'est parce que il était
tellement content de l'issue de
l'ouverture de la deuxième partie que ça
allait un peu ça là comme comme quoi
provoquer de force trop voilà juridique
comme ça
parfois en fait vaut mieux de ne pas
trop content d'aller Virtu en fait
psychologiquement parlant
faire des choses à très catholiques pas
très catholique pas trop orthodoxe non
plus
donc B6 c'est en quelque sorte on peut
dire c'est en quelque sorte menace
[Musique]
ni avec le bonheur
t'imagines sa tête de tueur en série là
la tête de Baki
est-ce que toi
tu as déjà vu quand il fait cette tête
sinistre et qui te regarde avec sa tête
de tueur en série ça t'es déjà arrivé
d'être face à ça ou pas écoute je le
connais depuis l'âge très jeune
et j'aimerais depuis l'âge que quand il
est vrai encore le visage angélique et
donc si tu vis au moins si après
beaucoup beaucoup plus tard il avait
dégueu maniacal oui ça me faisait pas
trop peur parce que c'est juste que pour
moi il était toujours petit gosse quoi
il était juste beau non quand il était
jeune
maintenant il est diablesse
créatures dans le tableau de Caravage
il rigole il rigole tout d'un coup il
joue une partie il se met à se
concentrer et tout de suite quand il a
un visage qui change quoi
et là si tu le croises la nuit avec ce
visage là tu as vraiment l'impression
qu'il peut te tuer quoi Bob fuck
incroyable
d'ailleurs assez récemment j'ai vu au un
film fantastique sur ce que vous appelez
Bob faites un film Argentan sur un
joueur sur un tueur céréales
quoi presque presque qui avait la gueule
complètement angélique en fait j'ai déjà
de ce film malheureusement je me
rappelle plus comment ah d'ailleurs je
pense que peut-être c'était même le
titre du film
l'entrée ou comment
t'inquiète pas on va le voir lundi et tu
auras des efficaces signé tu devras
faire des dédicaces
non je comprends mais peut-être les
vidéos
par mois et peut-être ne sont pas trop
bien vendus
ils veulent des échiquier
par toi il y a le FAP qui arrive
je pense que c'était ça le titre du film
dans tous les cas le film excellent je
veux je vous recommande
même si bien sûr très violent
oui oui bien sûr
c'était
quelque chose non mais j'ai revu la
semaine dernière j'ai déjà parlé en
stream et j'ai revu quasiment c'est
incroyable comme c'est bien parce que
j'ai revu hit avec Al Pacino et de Niro
ça mal vieilli mais casino c'est
incroyable ça pas mal vieilli du tout en
fait donc ça ça va jamais c'est juste un
classique pour l'éternité et pourtant tu
sais ce n'est pas très bien le répéter
ça en fait ce film
c'est pas considéré comme l'un des
meilleurs films d'oscarcelles
toujours rester loin de plus populaire
mais il n'est pas considéré comme l'un
de ses meilleurs en fait mais du tout
c'est le même le même paradoxe que avec
l'un de mes auteurs préférés donc pauvre
il a réalisé un film qui s'appelle
Shogun
j'ai toujours adoré ce film je l'ai vu
peut-être 15 fois et pourtant il est
considéré comme son plus grand plop et
le plus grand flop de tous les acteurs
principal du film ça détruit plusieurs
carrières juste pourtant le film
après De Niro il joue pas très bien quoi
comme d'hab il fait le toujours la même
tête non
pas il était toujours il était jamais
l'un de mes préférées tout simplement
parce que oui
en fait il faut toujours le même rôle
the Irishman c'est fou j'ai pas je l'ai
pas encore vu c'est incroyable à chaque
fois que je veux le voir j'ai le
problème c'est que j'ai refait hit et en
plus Baki il me dit hier que lundi la
revue Le Parrain et ok je vais être
obligé de revoir aussi et à chaque fois
ça tourne quoi tu es toujours obligé de
revoir parce que le parrain ça fait
peut-être deux trois ans que je l'ai pas
vu ok je dois refaire par un par un deux
par un 3 évidemment mais ok ça te prend
8 heures
non mais c'est long mais tu es obligé de
refaire mais tu peux regarder juste les
petits extraits sur Youtube je sais mais
bon le parrain je peux pas ce que je
peux parfois d'ailleurs et je dois
refaire ce Scarface aussi
c'est non mais c'est dur Scarface ça
fait trop longtemps que je l'ai pas vu
d'après vous d'ailleurs mais chers amis
qui est qui pourrait être le meilleur
acteur parmi les joueurs d'échec les
plus connus je parle
parce que moi je pense que j'ai une
réponse claire à cette question mais si
on vous
certes sinon
j'aurais dit qu'il y a pas blanc qui
je pense que
ok très limité au niveau de choix de
rôle bien sûr très limité il a peu de
choses qui auraient pu jouer mais sinon
elle aurait pu faire ça très bien je
pense
surico
dans son cas peut-être que de rôle
comico
bon alors d'un de deux
quand on a un truc dans ce cas là les
questions c'est alors
force non
je veux gagner le Paris
d'ailleurs et je serais très content
d'ailleurs c'est intéressant à quel
point le contour du 8 a été bien
finalement c'est pas tout pour te
protéger la tour mais c'est aussi de
pouvoir
la suite de souvenirs
donc comme je l'ai dit aussi que une
fois elle va voir que ça n'a pas marché
ah ouais il ferme il va fermer
bien sûr tu peux mais je pense que le
temps passion de
dingue c'est pas trop grande élevage
il va il va faire cette nuit
arrêtez l'hémorragie se refaire et donc
commencer
une nouvelle vie demain
je pense que je suppose que c'est bien
ça ce que
ça y est
[Musique]
d'ailleurs ça va être comme il est archi
franc
pendant les conférences de presse ça va
être très intéressant qu'est-ce qu'il
faut il va dire sur sa réflexion de 50
minutes avant d'arriver jusque
j'avais pas encore envie de pisser
donc j'ai bu de l'eau et j'ai attendu
[Rires]
c'est un acteur porno
d'ailleurs il y a le cours le tribunal
c'est quoi qu'est-ce qui se passe
juridiquement je suis pas au courant des
dernières avancées
massivement ils vont chercher une nul
quoi
mais regarde je pense qu'il se change
[Musique]
là au moins on est là le choix donc
partir bientôt rester encore
mais il va partir je pense qu'il faut
partir
un jour
aujourd'hui ouais ouais ouais ouais
on a fait à côté il est mort de rire
très heureux de la petite nulle Fab
le problème c'est que si vous continuez
à jouer ce positionne avec le noir ça
veut dire que vous faites fautes de 7 de
toute manière après
de toute façon si vous vous allez pas
gagner ça tu vas devoir jouer des quatre
qui a essayé de gagner ce type de
position parfois
et parfois réussi même moi je pense que
c'est un seul sinon tous les autres bah
bien sûr
plus tendance
dans un autre contexte oui pas dans ce
contexte là
par contre je peux vous faire monter
quand même malgré tout que après fou de
cette fou de cette tour de 7 ce qui est
cool pour le noir s'il veut le jouer
cette position que comme ça ils auront
l'accès
sur A6 pour la tour après il peut te
faire
ce type de tour là en fait tu vas jouer
pour faire nul avec les noirs
c'est pas mieux quoi non je suis pas
Millau moi je sais pas moi bien non plus
Jojo je suis et je joue moi aussi je
veux juste continuer et je joue et si je
joue je après je joue H5 et j'attends
non moi
aussi tu as envie de quand tu continues
de pisser
dans le chat du tournoi
chez toi ça fonctionne plus
parce que tu veux économiser l'eau
[Rires]
il devient qui discipline cool joue en
cours
maintenant à cette année en tant que
cette peur
[Musique]
il a une demi-heure de retard de retard
et il joue pour gagner
le courage
très bizarre ça gestion de match
bah peut-être après la fin du match on
pourra écrire tout en thèse sur tout un
test sur son comportement
psychologique je connais même le titre
du thèse qu'elle mouche les piquets quoi
[Rires]
ah c'est complexe c'est bizarre ce fou
des sept quand même enfin bizarre c'est
pas un mauvais coup mais
il était stressé pas possible et tout
d'un coup il joue un truc on sait pas
pourquoi
est-ce que c'est un bon coup bah c'est
pas un mauvais coup c'est un coup
correct mais
d'ailleurs je dois me corriger peut-être
après faute de cette tour de cette
Colette de 4 tout reste peut-être un
meilleur joueur vaut mieux jouer
6 mais tu vois l'ordi d'un avantage
après cavalier prend
ah non moi ça c'est bien trop faim pour
moi
ah d'ailleurs une fois j'ai vu le coup
bien sûr je la donne bien sûr je l'adore
les noirs sont en train de
YouTube
profiter que pour frapper
[Musique]
total bien sûr
un tel coup
alors pas de conneries alors pas de fou
de cette parce que quand
pour les deux pas grand chose à dire ici
tu insistes
faut prendre cette
couleur
impressionnant what mais l'ordinateur a
beaucoup plus impressionnant mais ça il
peut pas avoir non c'est trop dur
donc à cause de ça il va pas faire la
suite
bon écoutez je pense que je vais aussi
ma place à mon collègue Fab
tu veux souffler mais tu reviens ou pas
après ou là tu souffres complètement je
veux suivre et ça dépend de ce qui se
passe parce que la position de tel que
des grosses tendances que peut-être vous
allez plus me répondre tu vas bouffer je
pense bon allez peut-être à bientôt
peut-être non
après j'ai la bouffé ici hein si tu veux
une soupe si tu veux
là c'est comme tu veux c'est si tu veux
bouffer ici j'avais 6 ans
tu peux regarder dans le frigo tu vas
voir il y a plein de season ça te plaît
tu peux hein
mais ce qui va m'enlever moter le pain
de la bouche c'est toi qui avait dit ça
une fois chez proposé un de dîner un six
ans je ne vais pas tenter le pain de la
bouche quoi j'adore tu as des belles
expressions
mais c'est pas mes expressions
stéphanoise
[Musique]
on est mercredi c'est parce que le
weekend
bon j'ai continué bon je vais manger la
pizza là dans la rue derrière fermée
je sais plus quoi faire quoi je suis
allé manger de l'Est Arméniens
il ouvre que le soir
du coup bon j'ai su enfin
il peut être bien digne
et ouais une question de retour c'était
normal de l'épaule d'un F2
c'était pas terrible en fait c'était il
y avait du B5
juste répéter une partie qu'il fallait
pas répéter donc il sait pas avant où il
y a quelque chose qui s'est mal passé
mais on sait pas exactement quoi ok mais
cavaliers de retour pourquoi pas
on espère quand même
c'est extraordinaire ce qui est en train
de se passer Fab Ding qui va peut-être
jouer le gain bah c'est pas mal pour
l'intérêt du match on va dire
il va rejaillir vers E5 C4 ou B6 C4
donc là il jaillit complètement
il peut il peut finir par être mieux
quoi
en tout cas c'est plus un épaule
maintenant de trouver des coups pour nul
ce qui est pas commun quand elle est
blanc et que tu envoies une prépa enfin
et
tu peux même pas essayer de sécher avec
moi
parce que
[Musique]
comme dame 5 échange les dames ou bon
mais en fait il est rentré dans son
match ça y est
il était pas début de la partie tu es
pas vraiment rentrée dedans même mais il
est très peu il avait peur d'une prepa
ou quoi le mec en fait tu es nul il a
pas de prépa je le défonce sera je sais
pas ce qui s'est passé dans sa tête à un
moment donné mais ça a complètement
changé
mais d'ailleurs c'est bizarre qui n'est
pas
enfin je veux dire si tu joues ça que
Ding se sont répertoire normal qu'il a
déjà joué tu as dû regarder quand même
quoi
il se rappelle pas peut-être qu'il a
mélangé peut-être enfin je sais pas en
plein de choses
mais bien joué regarde la dépôt il sait
que il a pas la tête qu'il a pas regardé
qu'il prend des scènes
à chaque fois
c'était plusieurs que je vais prendre F6
oui ce que tu laisses l'option en prise
avant il y a pas qu'à y prendre des 5 à
cause
parce que c'est cloué
il y a pas d'imprent des cinq à cause de
dame prend le 3 il fallait aussi voir
que du coup le plan c'est cavalier B6
qui est ici 4 de base tu avais quand
même enfin tu as mis un double été tours
déjà c'est un coup qui va un peu à
l'envers quoi non mais c'est bien qu'il
a repris confiance parce que c'est vrai
que il y a deux coups il peut faire des
quatre pour pour égaliser quoi pour
faire nul
et donc ok il fait le choix courageux
et
probablement juste d'ailleurs en fait
avec cette partie
parce que il aurait pu complètement
couler
aujourd'hui mais ouais mais du coup
c'est une époque qui fait pas une grande
partie
qui rentre là-dedans qui oublie sa prépa
ou qui a pas de prépa ou qui j'en sais
rien quoi
et qui bon ok il doit arriver à sécher
maintenant sinon
ça a pas l'air dramatique non plus mais
non mais c'est relou
c'est vrai qu'en fait même si genre
cahier des quatre des six j'avais
l'embêter il prend des cinq
et qu'il a le temps de faire à 4 avec
les Noirs peut-être il nous fixe un peu
et
ça peut être grand chose mais ouais
c'est ouais
il a plein de plans en fait c'est vrai
il faudra tu fais planner quoi
bon après tu dois pouvoir faire et puis
c'est la vie il faut savoir souffrir des
fois dans les matchs et pas perdre mais
du coup tu es un peu moins bien prévu
quoi
mais n'oublions pas que digne il était
juste un peu moins bien après le GF qui
l'a oublié et il a implosé en deux trois
coups enfin là faut vraiment pas que
Yann il implose quoi de son côté parce
que si tu commences à jouer deux trois
coups à côté comme la fille tu vas
perdre instantanément quoi
saisir
en tout cas c'est un moment important du
match là pour pour Yann
dans le chat c'est là que l'expérience
du match précédent peut jouer c'est vrai
oui c'est possible être la réminiscence
de mauvais souvenirs
ça qui est beau dans le commentaire
sportif
en fonction du résultat
[Musique]
après le résultat évidemment
mais en tout cas
voilà d'après 10 nul au 35ème coup par
répétitions
je n'ai pas entendu claquer la porte
il se passe quoi
ce que tu veux dire par là c'est que
s'il est blanc
te joue ça mais bon il est mal placé ce
qu'il y avait après il va arrêter de
trop grave mais genre j'esquive je
t'attaque
bon a priori tu dois revenir sur tes pas
donc
ça a pas l'air grandiose après aller
là-bas si jamais tu avais des rebonds
vers l'avant ça pourrait s'entendre mais
là c'est pas trop le moment je dirais
c'est pas grandiose ce que j'ai fait
mais je vais je vais tenir parce que
c'est vrai qu'en fait objectivement
c'est pas la fin du tout des haricots
pour lui c'est quasi égal mais il est
plutôt du moins mon côté quoi c'est à
lui de trouver le bon setup et pas faire
des rares parce que effectivement comme
la disque cavalier il va arrondir son E5
son B6 il va venir là il va vous
apprécier sur B2 sur E3
et voilà et c'est vrai que là on se dit
tiens on reste si le pion est en F2 ce
serait plus simple
et pareil pour le grand rock qui dit
qu'il y a deux pour faire B4 etc ouais
c'est pas enfin sans qu'il fait rien et
même si tu fais BK tu fais plus de trou
qu'autre chose dans ta position tu auras
plus tenir la caisse C4 ni à C3 ou
peut-être je peux
rentrer après donc
non c'est plus un coup comme qui est
Descartes qu'il faut regarder
ok C3 il est là où il doit être en fait
il bloque l'entrée sur la colonne il met
une pression là-dessus il est il est pas
mal
vous avez des questions qui avaient la
carte
pourquoi pas que cavalier
formation
important
c'est pratique tu vois je regarde
j'aurais dû peut-être faire six hommes
évidemment encore à ce truc là je pense
c'était mieux en fait demain je ferai
quoi on va pas être bien
j'ai tout un peu de pain de la bouche
quoi
de la bouche fait évidemment elle est
connue mais tu l'avais dit dans très
loin vraiment comme si c'était en train
enfin j'aurais pu à bouffer quoi c'était
ah mais je crois que c'était ton dernier
quoi aussi là ça va tu as été livré tu
as beaucoup j'ai moins l'impression que
peut-être je t'en avais une miette mais
c'est pas vraiment le pain quoi
je pense c'est expression stéphanoise
en tout cas ça réfléchit
côté n'est pas maintenant la pression a
changé de camp
mouche changer d'âne
de la bouche mais c'est
aussi cette expression
de vieux quoi
c'est juste une expression
non mais ici on l'a aussi mais ouais les
gens ils en Alsace
c'est tout le monde connaît cette
expression
tout le monde ne l'a dit pas quoi c'est
ça
mauvais plan de pousser à 4 pour un seul
qui est en B5 ouais ouais non ça c'est
ouais kata en fait fassiez gaffe dans
beaucoup de suggestions vous aimez bien
pousser les pions non ça peut être bien
mais un pion ça recule pas quoi donc
une fois qu'il est poussé la casse B4 tu
la cèdes aussi et puis en plus même
juste un simple kb6
quand même bon donc c'est juste une
faiblesse après si c'est pour jouer avec
B3 reprend le contrôle de la casse C4 et
faire qui est B5 qui est D4 là ça peut
être intéressant c'est une question de
tempo mais donc voir si on tient B3 qui
est ici qui arrive etc mais
ça paraîtra affaiblissant après c'est
une question de tempo comme tout hein
bon de toute façon faut toujours parler
aux échecs quand même mais ouais faites
gaffe au coup de pions en fait c'est pas
un signifiant du tout ça a l'air quoi
parce qu'on se dit oui bon le pion
c'est la pire pièce je peux le perdre au
pire on s'en fout ouais on s'en fout pas
trop quoi
et qui prend des seins qui se passe quoi
et B6 merci au revoir
tu te prends des couloirs multiples
[Musique]
désolé pour le petit le petit bug là on
est rentré dans le dans le vif du sujet
mais Yann doit probablement jouer pour
cavaler des quatre et essayer de fermer
la porte mais comme on l'a montré il y a
quelques minutes la position sera certes
égale d'après l'ordinateur mais un peu
plus difficile à jouer pour les blancs
voilà en fait on va dire les blancs faut
plus qu'il fasse la précision ouais les
noirs
[Musique]
pierre tu te trompes c'est pas grave
alors si le pion était en F2 ce serait
mieux au blanc
on peut plus reculer quoi c'est terrible
difficile comme garant 30 30 40
c'est pas pareil alors il a joué qui a
eu des quatre évidemment c'était le coup
logique et il se barre
[Musique]
C4
et tu as vu comment à quel point ça se
retourne c'est digne qui réfléchissait
pendant des heures qui
qui se laissait mettre sous pression et
là il est tout sourire regarde il sourit
non c'est pas un sourire
ce serait beau que demain il va arriver
il va prendre 10 kg quoi tu regardes moi
aussi j'ai un bide ça va être le Shiba
comme ça
[Musique]
disait que le tennis est une partie
d'échec et Fab a dit les échecs sont un
match de tennis complexe
ah il est plus fringant qu'hier ouais
bon après hier moi je l'ai pas trop vu
mais en tout cas il a l'air bien digne
on va voir c'est petit peut-être que là
il a il a peut-être un 20 25 % de chance
de gagner alors attends je vais aller
aider
donc probablement mon époux va devoir un
peu coulisser les tours de ce côté qui
là bon elle par exemple se fait
absolument plus rien enfin
elle aurait pu être utile ici si
beaucoup plus tôt dans la partie quand
je reviens en arrière il voulait faire
ça et qui est peut-être un échange et
qu'elle joue quoi le nom de la colonel
mais ça c'est pas du tout passé comme ça
le scénario quoi et du coup maintenant
les tours elles sont un peu enfin elle
ouais elle se réveille là-bas on préfère
quoi donc il va perdre du temps sûrement
par décaler vers la gauche
repère du temps pour décaler vers la
droite
je reviens attaquer je reviens à
attaquer ton pion
est-ce que là il est chaud pour le
training de Gaube on va lui demander
écoute à taux quand il convient de
revient et il est parti acheter du pain
justement
j'espère que tu en prendras pas
ce serait beau quoi
non peut-être il est en train de le
bouffer tu arrives quand tu tu le
plaques quoi
ces quatre c'est une bonne idée ou faut
vraiment garder la position fermée à E4
tu veux dire bah en fait c'est pas si
arrive pas juste ce pain là le cas juste
super et tu te fais bouffer donc
c'est une question de réalisation et ça
va être dur à réaliser pas impossible
même jamais quoi
des fois il y a des il y a des coûts
qu'on peut juste pas jouer
partir assez intéressante partie qui
change la physionomie du match en tout
cas ça c'est l'information qu'on peut
vous lâcher à 13h15 et on voit et c'est
une époque qui vient plus s'asseoir
c'est marrant quand même c'est toujours
les mêmes scénarios
monter dominé tu viens plus tard ce soir
ça y reviens mais regarde il est courant
quoi qu'il en soit
ça va être tellement vrai ça il est
énervé quoi
ouais mais c'est relou non
bah il fait oui il fait pas une bonne
partie normalement avec les Blancs tu
dois pas te prendre la pression surtout
avec le scénario des deux premières et
le sens du match
mais donc Ding un peu comme dans tous
les tournois qu'il a enfin important un
peu comme aux candidats un peu dans
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait il faut qu'il
chauffe
regarde ici alors il y a rien de grave
encore mais ouais désagréable bah disons
faut aussi qu'il moralement il se mette
dans cet état d'esprit de devoir
défendre ce qui était venu un peu pour
écraser ou disant bon au pire il joue
bien l'ouverture je fais nul et on en
aura plus ce qu'il a voulu faire avec en
laissant des quatre sauf que on en parle
encore quoi et moi je trouve qu'il
ressemble vraiment au Beaux-Arts
parce que Hikaru ils ont fait Hauser
ils ont mis Karu en tête de mais je
trouve vraiment qui ressemble à un
époque je connais pas
possible c'est méchant qui crache les
femmes
Mario en fait
et il saute comme ça
mais là il m'a l'air moins influant tu
vois c'est plus un Bowser quand il a
pris un peu des coups quoi il
est un peu des étoiles
Thierry c'est Todd ouais toi tu vois ce
que c'est non
je vois bien je vois bien en Toad
il mettrait une peau plus son Donkey
Kong
tu vois qui c'est donc
mario c'est qui
Mario ils ont mis c'est terrible ils ont
mis Gotham
ok rapport non non
[Musique]
il m'a appelé
et Wario c'est qui il y a pas de Wario
pour le moment
mais j'aurais quand même bien revendiqué
[Musique]
ils ont mis Kawana et je pense que
j'aurais pu revendiquer le Mario parce
que je suis d'origine italienne
mais bon mais je vais rappeler Mario
quoi
non si Gotham et Mario je veux être le
Wario c'est le
je crois qu'ils vont nous sortir un film
de Mario là
ce sera mieux que les Marvel à la con tu
regardes non je veux plus les voir là
c'est sont trop décevant quoi c'est plus
possible genre essayer beaucoup de
chance mais là c'est bon quoi
ça n'existe plus en fait c'est vrai que
je suis à Luigi c'est vrai il est mince
il a un grand nez il est toxique c'est
sûr que c'est moi en fait ouais c'est
sûr one Luigi 100% et ils ont mis bottes
pour Yoshi ouais ok et anacram Link pour
princesse Peach oui il y a une
ressemblance
[Musique]
ou l'inverse moi je sais plus hein je me
perds
est-ce que cavalier E6
mais en fait vous êtes cloué ça va être
difficile à te faire E4
c'est compliqué il veut pas quoi ouais
ça t'a pas le droit et moi je te
laisserai le jouer je te ferai des
prends en quatre je dirais échec quoi
[Rires]
[Musique]
bon pourquoi pas ça je sais pas c'est
une bonne idée mais bon
là de faire ça quand même
mais ça doit aller mais bon en fait je
sais pas mais tout va je pense mais
j'aurais envie de rien ça me rendrait
fou comme position
en fait j'ai pas si je peux ne pas faire
je vais peut-être pas prendre aussi
c'est parce que des cinq ça reste
potentiellement une faiblesse chinoise
quoi et là bon on la renforce et quand
on prend pour être France pour affûter
les cases blanches mais on aime bien au
moins avoir le fou et faire des trucs
par là-bas tu peux pas et là en fait du
coup c'est juste on renforce les noirs
on leur donne peut-être un pion passé
s'ils font le 5D 4 un jour donc je sais
pas j'ai l'impression de les aider alors
ça va peut-être mais
pour réussir à faire le 4 mais tu vas
quand même pas y arriver en fait si tu
as déjà même des quatre ça pour aller et
te faire mal mais en fait tu vas juste
prendre une découverte quand même ouais
qui prend des deux mais
genre pareil que tu vas jamais y arriver
en fait le 4 c'est pas c'est pas ton
idée en fait c'est juste pas dans le tu
vois tout le monde veut faire enfin
c'est parti comme réflexe en fait c'est
normal que vous vouliez faire des quatre
mais pas l'inverse
ah non ça va pas aller
non le pion des cinq c'est une faiblesse
des Noirs donc après bon ben en
contrepartie donne de l'espace il est à
sauter en C4 il fait des trucs mais bon
j'ai envie de dire si vous avez envie
d'apprendre l'option isolé on a fait une
série de 20h avec Vlad dessus comme
disait Baki hier soir c'est la meilleure
tentative d'explication du pion isolé de
l'histoire des échecs en réalité donc si
vous voulez apprendre
vous allez si vous regardez les 10 je
crois que c'est 19h30 ou un truc comme
ça si vous passez si vous regardez les
19h30 vous comprendrez que c'est pas le
cas que le plan
bon vous comprendrez quand même toujours
pas pour le revoir deux trois quatre
cinq fois mais mais
ouais ça vaut le coup très belle série
tu l'as regardé toi mais tu veux
toujours aussi mal le purge en fait non
mais c'est hyper intéressant le problème
c'est que faut voir tout le temps parce
que
même moi en fait là je me rappelle pas
de trop de trucs
bon en fait mon problème c'est que là je
les jouets pas avant donc j'ai pas de
réflexe c'est pas mon répertoire
pourquoi tu as joué F3 alors bah en fait
un truc
c'est pas la même chose en fait là
c'était 7 structure si le je sais pas il
fait fou aussi ça y est enfin là on va
faire 4 ouais on voulait
c'est pas la même chose
les ouais la position elle a évolué et
la structure de pion évolué en fait
ouais ça c'est un truc que vous on joue
pas tout seul aux échecs malheureusement
pas je sais pas ça serait cool de faire
son truc on s'en fout de ce que
l'adversaire il fait mais pas du tout
faut s'adapter et entre cette structure
ou s'il y a des points vous avez un duo
pion sans trop les tours bien placés on
avance on leur roule dessus puis
l'activité des pièces c'est pas la même
enfin rien n'est pareil en fait
c'est pas la même chose
pas une position quoi
complexe
telle est la vie des échecs
mais comme tu dis c'est un sac quelque
chose d'important à comprendre aux
échecs et je suis pas péjoratif mais
c'est que tu es pas seul à jouer t'es
pas seuls la situation change et
peut-être tu voulais un truc à un moment
et puis une pièce bouge
puis tu veux plus quoi
c'est comme ça
j'ai appris tout passe ou ne passe pas
par la tactique
je comprends jamais rien au final c'est
des structures depuis alors déjà nous on
a fait une très bonne vidéo série de
vidéos qui est pas du tout regardé pour
le coup parce que les gens pensent que
c'est trop complexe et donc pas
pédagogique attention mais
malheureusement c'est la base pour
apprendre c'est la série sur les enjeux
des ouvertures c'est un bon début c'est
vraiment superficiel et c'est que le
début mais déjà pour la plupart des gens
c'est déjà trop compliqué donc si vous
n'êtes pas capable de d'ingursiter les
informations en fait dans cette série en
fait c'est juste n'essaie pas de
comprendre les échecs quoi même les
structures même les structures enfin
c'est juste faut quitte en fait enfin
pas quick le jeu
si déjà ça c'est trop compliqué en fait
c'est on va pas rien ne sera simple bah
après on pourra t'expliquer 100000 fois
par vidéo ce que c'est un clouage mais
ouais c'est c'est que la base
mais ouais les structures il y en a
beaucoup en fait on a beaucoup et là
c'est
c'est que le enfin comme je disais là
c'est que l'introduction aux structures
c'est juste le bagage minimum pour pour
déjà un peu voir qu'est-ce qui peut se
passer ou pas
ça c'est une erreur pas faire enfin
intellectuel je veux dire c'est parce
que vous jouez pas tel ou telle
ouverture il faut pas regarder pour
autant
je voulais pas regarder les parties dans
les dans les livres quoi c'était pas
mauvais ça ne sert à rien mais j'ai été
con enfin je le sais maintenant et à un
moment j'ai compris et je l'ai pas fait
toute ma vie quoi mais
oui il faut regarder parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de reminiscence de trucs
servent dans un cas et qui ah oui ça me
rappelle ça et Machin
faut pas avoir cette feignantise
intellectuelle en tant que 1250 on mis
surtout d'apprendre les fins de parties
avec les pions vous confirmez oui mais
bon tu fais évidemment qu'il faut la
prendre mais d'ailleurs il y a plein de
vidéos aussi sur la chaîne facile
là-dessus je pense j'ai dû faire 3h30 ou
4 heures de contenu mais une fois que tu
as passé 10 heures dessus ben ça suffit
c'est juste faut la prendre mais c'est
pas mais tu vas pas faire que ça va pas
faire que ça une fois que tu sais
transformer des finales avec un pion de
plus ça suffit à 150 et là justement là
la série sur les enjeux des des
structures de pions bah ça fait partie
d'un contenu intéressant à regarder et
voilà tout peut être intéressant après
faut pas faire que un truc de toute
façon parce que le jeu d'échec est assez
vaste et large et riche pour que tout
soit plus ou moins intéressant et donc
voilà c'est comme si vous faites que de
la tactique et encore c'est assez utile
mais bon un moment faut aussi faire
autre chose ou faire que de l'ouverture
enfin attaquer pour le coup c'est quand
même suivant les profils de joueurs
c'est quand même assez important je vois
par exemple je sais qu'il était dans le
chat tout à l'heure à taux je sais pas
s'il est encore là mais s'il est encore
là tu vois de de par son jeu
tu vois que il est nettement plus fort
stratégiquement que tactiquement donc là
il y a une marge de progression il y a
une asymétrie dans son jeu c'est à dire
que stratégiquement il pourra encore
progresser mais il est trop bloqué par
la tactique par le manque de tactique
donc là faut vraiment qu'il travaille la
tactique tu auras deux joueurs qui
seront dans un autre profil mais disons
qu'il faut essayer de progresser de
manière un peu un peu partout un peu
partout ouais mais évidemment commencez
par les finales la tactique et la
stratégie les ouvertures juste si vous
avez un petit répertoire ça ça suffit
quoi pas besoin de mais bon je préfère
son son profil c'est plus facile de le
renforcer évidemment mais je veux dire
du coup là dans son cas de figure faire
deux heures de tactique quand il a le
temps c'est
vraiment positif quoi
en ce moment notamment les finales pour
avoir des vrais armes long terme ouais
mais c'est important
au boulot alors
regardez globalement je pense ça fait
progresser
à des rapides sur Internet bon oui mais
les matchs champion du monde je pense
que tu progresses parce que ça va dans
la profondeur donc et ces quatre d'un
meuf de bah il a renforcé des cas tu
auras ses 8 et il va attendre
après ouais il y a un truc peut-être
intéressant c'est qu'il y avait les
prend à 3
qui semble gagner un pion
mais probablement ce 400 litres
finalement non mais là
aussi
puis on prend à 3 et tu peux plus gagner
le cavalier C3 mais genre c'est marrant
parce qu'on discute de ça et là il se
trouve que c'est jamais l'idée au 4 mais
sauf que là sur qui prend le 4 ça marche
pour des raisons tactiques mais c'est
toujours pas l'idée mais
concrètement on fait un truc bizarre ils
ont mis une pièce en prise et donc
[Musique]
c'est enfin c'est toute la difficulté
des échecs après c'est pour ça qu'on
peut pas résumer des parties mais il a
fait un clouage tiens il a mis une tour
en face d'un pion oui bon oui aussi mais
c'est plus que ça en fait les échecs
donc dans mes deux
est-ce que à 4 et un coup
à quatre noirs
ça sert à rien en fait
c'est pas du tout une menace oui c'est
ça et A4 tu fous ton pion sur une case
où il va quand même être touché
en fait pour l'instant ça va commencer à
menacer
[Musique]
une menace directe
tu mets là juste qu'elle prend à trois
ou qu'elle prend B2 d'ailleurs
B2 c'est forcé ça menace qui a été un
cavalier F2 tu tu touches tout partout
c'est un genre de
de comme parler de Mario c'est comme
quand tu prends la petite toile tout
tout tout tout tout tout tout tout tout
tout
j'aurais pensé une tortue que tu jettes
qui rebondit qui touche tout et qui
défonce tout quoi
[Musique]
oui bon j'ai vaguement joué oui bon j'ai
terminé non parce qu'en gros
j'avais pas vraiment de console tu vois
j'ai jamais vraiment joué quoi alors des
fois je t'ai pas tu es content tu joues
toute l'après-midi mais c'était pas donc
en fait c'est pour ça quoi j'ai pas une
grande expertise du truc mais je vois
[Musique]
la fleur quoi après il envoie des trucs
aussi mais dans les anciens et après
les petites boules quoi il attaque les
gens avec des boules quoi
mais
donc ouais je suis pas méga expert Mario
quoi
pour la première fois au stade
je sais pas entre 6 et 7 ans Max quoi
avec ton papa vous avez tous les deux
ouais mais je
ok en fait le vrai souvenir que j'ai je
t'aime mon grand-père
du coup tu étais dans quel type de
tribune et tribune supporter
[Musique]
possible que j'étais en latéral quoi
genre un billet de 20 francs par terre
ou un ou deux je sais pas et du coup il
était allé à la boutique il m'a acheté
un petit drapeau j'étais très heureux
quoi j'étais avec mon drapeau
et tu devais être bien
mon petit drapeau avec la panthère
dessus comme ça
tu vas être super heureux quoi j'étais
très heureux quoi
tu te rappelles contre qui vous aviez
joué contre Lyon non
je sais plus que cette
huit ans j'imagine que Lyon Lyon
Saint-Étienne c'est pas forcément
à l'endroit
c'est 8 jouets mais en plus j'ai
l'impression que c'était moins violent
quoi
il y a moins de haine ouais maintenant
c'est un peu abusé je trouve
là c'est trop quoi
et pour ça je tactique pour une prépa de
trois mois pour un tournoi 1600 filles
comme on l'a dit ça dépend de enfin on
peut pas te répondre comme ça en réalité
c'est il y a un peu d'individualisme
il a 1600 filles il veut savoir combien
de temps il doit passer en pourcentage
sur les écarts statistiques
on peut pas te répondre comme ça sans te
connaître 100% du temps non après il
fait beaucoup de tactique c'est quand
même le truc le plus important si tu
veux faire du court terme c'est le mieux
si tu veux faire du long terme pas
forcément
il est très chaud pour savoir ce que je
mets dans le kebab mais ça dépend quoi
ça fait 6 fois quand il pose la question
il va se faire ban en fait vivement ton
livre tactique il sera de quelle couleur
pour se marier avec les deux premiers
mais ce sera rouge aussi je crois
qu'on a vu la cour il sera rouge dans un
ton très comme le premier en fait comme
gagner aux échecs mais ça va être
gagnant de la tactique quoi et c'est le
premier vit tactique je pense qu'on va
en écrire au moins deux ouais ça va être
tactique soft et je pense qu'on va en
faire un tactique hard avec un bouffe
quoi on avait on a on a l'objectif et le
projet de mettre 1000 exercices
tactiques
[Musique]
pas trop dur mais quand même ça monte un
peu en puissance mon premier livre de
tactile ça va et puis il est détente des
temps de vacances toutes les prendre
dans le train à la plage
voilà c'est sympa surtout les mots mêlés
les mots mêlés c'est magnifique
d'ailleurs tu as su pour les réseaux
mais en fait j'ai l'impression qu'il
soit ils ont changé un truc mais en fait
moi j'ai l'impression que les dire dans
le mauvais sens
tu peux les faire là je suis à fond mais
j'aime bien de gauche à droite ou en bas
ils sont plus que normaux ah c'est
dommage je vais demander qu'il recharge
c'est beau quand c'est partout tu suces
pas mal enfin j'espère mais je crois et
après il y en a un autre très très
tactique tactique
1000 exercices pour progresser ou pas de
quiz pas de mots croisés pas de mots
fléchés
tu te fais massacrer la gueule en fait
là c'est pas un livre de plage du coup
ça peut être sympa la plage aussi c'est
la salle de muscu tu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et tu tapes
qui avait lieu ces quatre mais c'est
marrant c'est le même thème sur B2 sur 3
sur A3 partout mais en fait la présence
du pur à 3 est vraiment problématique
ce que disait Vlad immédiatement c'est
qu'en fait ta F3 et il a trouvé un carré
d'acade mais je pense c'est juste ça le
coup en fait
je me demande si tu en as
genre
[Musique]
prends des cinq aussi
et tu protèges le 3
mes rois et F8
et maintenant si je reviens en C5 il y a
un peu plus de
ça
ok je comprends mais c'est dur
ouais alors bah sinon même dans mes
fuites quoi comme ça
disons ça c'est logique et d'un
investisse
ouais ça me fascine que ce soit égal
après kb5 parce que
ouais
un peu des pièces en prises
tellement jamais allé pour ça juste ma
main elle aurait empêché de jouer un
truc pareil
le problème c'est que si tu es mal
partout des fois tu fais par défaut mais
tu es un peu
le pain de la bouche en prenant un pion
je sais pas c'est pour moi les trois
coups même après analyse avec l'ordi les
trois coups sont jouables oui parce que
damassave 5 croyait fuite qui est C3
on voit c'est pas le les il est pas dans
les dans le top 2 mais c'est celui que
j'aurais joué aussi et Caval F5 ça
m'aurait pas impressionné en vrai
parce que j'ai oui je me prépare un peu
pour la finale ça peut échanger enfin je
me serais pas senti mal sur cette case
F8 non en plus je me demande si là après
si on peut pas si ça nous de jouer même
faire B5
tu vois B5 B4 on fera défendre des 5
mais et tu pousses pousse-pousse ton
pion jusqu'à B3 et
damasset c'est le coup d'après ceci ok
bon bien pour notre feeling
tu étais content quand même sur cette
diagonale tu tapes déjà sur tout ce dont
tu as besoin de taper et tu tapes tape
tape
cette diagonale qui te plaît
est-ce que c'est pas l'heure de la pause
fable avant comme ça on l'a fait
maintenant on se fait pas avoir quand ça
va quand ça va rejouer ok vas-y parce
qu'on a le petit partenaire chez sarahma
donc on va envoyer la petite imagine que
tu es un dragon la petite petite pub
partenaire et on revient et on revient
dans une petite dizaine de minutes avant
le avant le dight note du coup comme ça
on aura
ensuite comme il faut à toute
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
salut on est de retour
ouais du coup voilà du quelques coups
depuis
[Musique]
que je suis parti il y avait pas mal de
couches
[Musique]
je suis parti en ce moment là je pense
il était surpris et il a réfléchi
des quatre et la maison
pour C8 je crois que c'est bien et ça
c'était sur le coup pour éviter les
problèmes avec les premiers deux qu'elle
prend à trois ou d'autres
on savait pas trop bon il a choisi
d'aller ici apparemment mais peut-être
là-bas c'était bon
il a fait ça
[Musique]
et je crois qu'on en est là et dit que
réfléchit bon qu'est-ce que j'ai à dire
il est moins bien longtemps 27 minutes
compteur 41 moi bien sûr les
drastiquement améliorer se pose parce
que le coralie est sur C4 il est parfait
le corolet sur E6 est parfait les tours
sont bien la dame sur 6 je l'adore
quand on veut pas réfléchir disons on
est un jour en blitz oui bah les
réactions typiques cr5 bien sûr
qu'est-ce qu'un virus avec ça jusqu'à H4
après quoi bon les Noirs vont gagner
beaucoup d'espace vont toujours menacer
H3 en affaiblissant la position blanche
encore
et si les blancs réagissent en jouant H4
sur H5 bah les réactions je parle de
plus si je veux pas réfléchir c'est
souvent justice que oui je souhaite avec
le décoller 5 en gros
pourquoi est-ce que pourquoi est-ce que
le noir je considère c'est plus facile
de jouer avec le noir moi même si c'est
objectivement ça reste peut-être
toujours égal tout simplement parce que
à long terme et ça peut se faire sentir
le roi blanc ne peut plus faible que le
roi adverse
c'est intéressant d'ailleurs il veut
donc comment
il vit échanger les cavaliers par
exemple
pour très vite doubler sur eux
et si il réussit à changer eux compteur
d'air le roi blanc devient vraiment
faible
donc et en plus comme ça il comment dire
il neutralise le cavalier Bessan qui
peut toujours retourner sur des quatre
en gros le cavalier
ok important aussi je suppose que sur
aussi important donc quand les
chaussettes
j'ai la flemme de calculer les variables
maintenant je viens de manger en fait et
à se copieux moi d'après la gueule
j'aime bien le coup d'après la gueule et
j'aime bien que comment dire il commence
de reprendre ses instincts d'un très
très très bon joueur quand même
ça y est peut-être
un petit peu rentrer dans le match je
l'ai dit déjà avant
pendant la deuxième partie mais
peut-être c'est un petit moment tournant
quand il voit quand même finalement ce
matériel
au moins je l'espère de toute manière je
peux vous assurer une chose que
les positions très agréables de jouer
avec le noir il y a aucun risque un peu
pressé et souvent on a pu arriver au
type de position ou comme quoi
si on l'ordinateur ça va être
objectivement égal mais ça va quand même
rester plus facile de jouer avec les
Noirs en pratique chiant d'ailleurs son
adversaire ne peut me chier il est très
bien dans ce type de pollution avec le
monde très très bien parce que en fait
quand le roi est faible ça donne
toujours le terrain pour prendre des
petits pièges et
pour les milliers fois je me répète et
comme ça à long terme un truc marche pas
maintenant un truc marche pas 10 couples
plus tard mais peut-être 15 coups plus
tard ça va marcher quand même
ce que j'ai recommandé à Ding c'est de
augmenter les pressions lentement se
donnait pas à chercher à gagner vite
fait parce que normalement ça va pas
marcher donc de voir les patientes
levez les positions pour gagner de
l'espace pour gagner une partie voilà
mais avec les Blancs là
tu pars
au feeling
je joue quand et je veux voir qu'est-ce
que donc il veut faire parce que quand
ça donne rien pour l'instant oui
[Musique]
si je me trompe pas quoi que je peux
mettre un peu
peut-être pas
il est bien possible enfin
il est bien possible que l'autre va
jouer ici ce que
déjà il est moins bien longtemps
[Musique]
c'est le coup numéro combien
on est au 27 là
je peux je suis presque sûr que je veux
perdre mon pari quand j'ai annoncé que
ça va être mieux le 35e par répétition
je pense que je veux perdre mon pari si
Dingo Z presser pour gagner avant
maintenant il va pas lâcher la faire
facilement il va essayer de ce monde
iranien
[Musique]
il a joué fou de cette vie
en loupant sur moi le sous-percoure
parce que si au lieu de
4 là les choses
auraient été
les hommes ne sont pas les ordures donc
c'est comme les positions est également
votre ROI est plus faible c'est payant
en fait c'est pas égal en fait c'est pas
tout à fait pas tout à fait et ça se
voit d'ailleurs on parle toujours de la
langue corporelle des joueurs regardez
sur une épaule
non non il est pas tout à fait
confortable parce que il comprend très
bien tout ce que je viens de dire que il
doit être précis et peut-être
pas que le cours suivant peut-être pas
que tout le temps
qu'il a mal fait au début
je pense que les regards fait de mal au
début
[Musique]
il s'attendait pas à ça et c'est normal
d'ailleurs parce que
quand
tu t'attends surtout au niveau tu
t'entends pas trop de sang que au
troisième quand même
c'est pas Carson personne il adore
n'importe quel type de l'estructure
carsbad qui arrive après ces cadres 5
E32
parce que la position devient très
stable et digne que non c'est pas un
joueur c'est pas tout à fait un joueur
de structure fixe oui il est ça bouge
oui il préfère que ça bouge
plus 0,3 03 bon 03
j'essaie de me rappeler maintenant
est-ce que je suis jamais arrivé à
interruption avec les noirs ou avec les
bons je pense que jamais
le type de position dans les situations
nettement plus favorables avec le gong a
été pas sur toi mais ça joue souvent sur
F3 non d'ailleurs avec les Blancs je
veux toujours peur de te le scénario
si le pion ne se retrouve
pourquoi est-ce que le pion sur froid
affaibli autant le roi
parce que si un jour le cavalier va
arriver sur E3 c'est tout homme
Octopussy
puis sinon 93
F3 affaiblit à ville 2e oui et en plus
ça donne envie de pousser le pion h
qui comme je viens d'expliquer tout à
l'heure va imposer une autre question
prochaine donc comment réagir donner
rien faire du tout de jouer H4
d'attendre jusqu'à H4
question les réponses sur lesquelles
parfois très dur en fait un peu pendant
des heures et de ne pas comprendre en
fait parce que tout est très concret en
fait
dans une position tu aurais jamais avec
H4 dans l'autre tu attends enfin
quoi ah oui
[Musique]
peut-être il a joué que vous les 7 7
parce que après J6 il n'a pas voulu
permettre
je vois pas trop de problèmes je sais ce
que les bus
5 à 4
ici
je veux dire que
mais ouais je sais pas pourquoi il fait
pas
intéressant si on va revoir cette
ouverture en match dans le match donc
pas sûr il est possible que peut-être
ils vont jouer
[Musique]
qu'une seule fois en fait
et au cas où il rejoue si tu étais digne
tu changes et tu joues la finale autre
chose ou tu veux voir ce qu'il a parce
qu'il a rien montrer je pense que
si il n'a jamais joué cette finale il va
pas le jouer dans ce match alors sinon
le jour aujourd'hui parce que c'est une
finale que qui demande beaucoup beaucoup
du travail quand même les finales est
bon mais tout le travail pas pendant le
match il faut savoir avant
donc
quand elle était quatre c'est le premier
réflexe
revient il vient de jouer d'ailleurs
pronostic
direct bien sûr et après Coralie
le retard à la pendule quoi
oui ça va
[Musique]
il faut dire aussi qu'il adresses pas
beaucoup de coups dans une position pas
trop chargée
est-ce que vous pouvez reprendre la
partie depuis le début et on peut la
faire une fois le temps que ni pour
revienne comme là il est pas là
je vais un peu vite parce que le direct
plus important les dépôt il a fait des
quatre du coup c'était peut-être une
petite surprise pas pour moi
parce que c'est une stratégie classique
de tester l'adversaire un peu partout au
début du match par contre quand
des 5 des 5 de la part de Jean de ma
surpris beaucoup tu pensais du cavalier
soit au troisième jour
[Musique]
on va voir
des petites surprises ici Cécile se
trouve ici donc pendant le stream j'ai
dit que peut-être elle va opter pour les
finales il faut F5 Game of Thrones
6 dans le 6 de moins 6 GF je me suis dit
peut-être
très intéressant compliqués
donc il a choisi cette ligne
qui est populaire depuis à ce long temps
fou de toi
maintenant on va pas trop rentrer dans
les détails dans pseudo est plus
précisions de quoi il s'agit elle a
expliqué moi jingle opté pour donc cette
ligne
qui est populaire depuis peut-être
quelques années déjà sauf que d'habitude
ça joue au collège 5 au lieu de
faut prendre cette dame cette tour c'est
la suite normale
dans les parties on a eu les mêmes avec
les cours à 5 à 3 joueurs avant
ouais
est-ce que c'est favorable au blanc ou
est-ce que c'est favorable noir ça reste
une question mais les bons veulent dire
que c'est favorable à eux parce que
quand ils vont préparer les pousser F3
E4 et les Noirs vont réagir sur ça en
poussant ce 5 les blancs auront lieu
accès à la case B5 s'oublie par
le groupe voilà donc les points veulent
dire que ça leur faveur alors qu'en
laissant c'est pour protéger le pion F3
E3 pour pouvoir jouer trois quatre donc
quand vous voulez
ici et pendant tout ce temps là on a
beaucoup c'est moi qui ai beaucoup de de
dingue du comportement de Ding parce que
il a eu déjà cette position dans sa
pratique intergueries il a fait très
confortablement nul contre guéri mais
ici aujourd'hui il est arrivé à cette
position indépendance
30 minutes sur sa pendule c'est que bien
sûr trois minutes
ce que enfin
guéri a joué ici dans ma vidéo ce 5 bien
sûr mais pour être au courant donc il a
préféré de avoir
plus ou moins le même style de la
position ou un joint que il défend
Descartes il veut jouer 4 donc l'idée de
les mêmes que
l'idée de à chaque fois se protéger des
cartes pour pouvoir pour ce cadre
les réactions ont été la même
toujours pareil et donc après
on va juste voir
peut-être ça va faire juste une alors
qui est le déception qui est le
déception
même si en quelque sorte ça confirme mon
pronostic de toute façon
de se voir mais encore plus vite mais
encore plus vite
sur ça
non non après quand il y a des quatre
bien sûr il va jouer parce que si tu
joues toujours avec le covalier sur ici
pendant ce mois-là à chaque fois quand
même non
ça va mais ça va pas être au 35e c'est
ça le problème allez la nul allez la
petite nul
ok alors là c'est la petite nulle qui
parle
c'est beau voilà
voilà
[Musique]
ils savent pas s'ils doivent signer ou
pas quoi
[Musique]
signalent
pas trop d'aventure alors
c'est beau les petites nuls
merci à tous d'avoir suivi
YouTube
ouais un peu décevant parce qu'il
pouvait il pouvait tenter là ici
il aurait pu essayer ouais c'était pas
mal l'idée de Vlad est provoquer là-bas
moi j'ai réessayé mais c'est bizarre
d'avoir un peu essayé mais pas trop oui
non c'est bizarre de ne pas essayer
quand tu es arrivé tu dois essayer
encore plus que avant
non mais c'est déjà
par rapport au scénario qu'on attendait
ce matin avant le début de la partie
c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle pour
dingue quand même il est pas au fond du
trou il est pas au fond du trou quoi il
a réussi à jouer une partie correcte et
donc il se relance dans le match
ouais bon bah sur ce mesdames et
messieurs merci d'avoir suivi et on se
retrouve demain matin 11h pour le direct
un petit peu plus tard sur Youtube pour
pour le résumer n'hésitez pas à taper
Blitz stream dans votre
moteur de recherche YouTube sur Youtube
et vous trouverez la vidéo d'ici
j'ai pas 1h30 je pense le temps que ça
se mette en ligne etc merci à tous ciao
ciao